Hallo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen beim Chaosradio 291.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei dem Podcast, der im Prinzip eine Telenovela ist.
Also eigentlich passiert seit, also in meinem Gefühl, wir sprechen gleich noch
genauer drüber, seit 20 Jahren dasselbe.
Nämlich Menschen glauben Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was das ist,
erklären wir auch gleich nochmal kurz, sei eine gute Idee. und dann kommen andere
Menschen, die sagen nein und dann landet es vor Gericht und das Gericht sagt auch nein.
Und wenn euch das alles bekannt vorkommt, haben wir heute eine frohe Nachricht
für euch. Heute wird alles anderes.
Ein Gericht hat ja gesagt. Ja zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio.
Herzlich willkommen, Konz. Guten Tag. Hallo, guten Tag. Den muss man dich noch
vorstellen? Ja bitte. Ich finde immer schön, wie du dich abmühst.
Danke. Konz ist mal wieder hier. Herzlich willkommen. Und Nibbler ist auch mal wieder da.
Mahlzeit. Man kennt Nibbler vom Club und vom Chaosradio, obwohl das auch schon
ein bisschen länger her ist.
Und du machst Dinge mit Telekommunikation. Das ist nicht zu viel versprochen, oder?
Ja, nee. Du weißt, wie Dinge passieren, also wie das tatsächlich mit dem Internet,
das aus der Wand fällt, passiert und noch mehr.
Und Mobilfunk, glaube ich, auch. Und Mobilfunk auch, genau.
Und jetzt habe ich mir vorgenommen, mir den Namen zu merken.
Aber jetzt muss ich das Pad nochmal aufmachen.
Wo ist das Pad hin? Da ist das Pad hin. Den Vornamen kennst du schon.
Ja, Daniel. Aber ich kann ja jetzt nicht sagen Daniel. Das ist der Daniel. Das ist der Daniel.
Daniel Moosbrocker. Daniel Moosbrocker ist Journalist. So sieht es aus.
Und zwar, willst du nochmal genauer sagen, wo?
Das erkennt man ja vielleicht. Na, ich bin freiberuflich unterwegs,
aber einige Sachen mache ich für den NDR bei Panorama und Steuerung F.
Genau, und das muss man immer dazu sagen, das kenne ich von einem anderen Podcast,
wo wir oft Leute einladen, die in Institutionen arbeiten oder manchmal für Institutionen.
Daniel Moosbrocker ist heute als Privatperson hier und spricht sozusagen nicht
für einen Sender oder eine Sendung. So, und wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen.
Nee, stopp, man muss noch eine Sache über dich wissen. Du hast wissenschaftlich
gearbeitet zu dem Thema, über das wir heute sprechen. Du hast nämlich worüber
deine Doktorarbeit geschrieben?
Ich bin noch dabei, sie gerade fertigzustellen und sie bald einzureichen.
Ich befasse mich seit vielen Jahren damit, was macht Überwachung und anlasslose
Überwachung mit Menschen, in meinem Fall der Doktorarbeit vor allem,
was macht sie mit journalistischer Arbeit?
Also wenn ich jetzt als Journalist weiß, okay, der Staat sammelt bestimmte Daten
über mich, wie prägt das meine journalistische Arbeit?
Darüber habe ich promoviert. oder bin dabei, sie abzuschließen.
Okay, dann dabei viel Glück, aber natürlich auch sehr gut, dass du heute hier bist.
So, und wir wollen über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sprechen und meine Position
hier im Chaos Radio, wo wir uns in der Sendung ein Thema raussuchen,
um das sozusagen so zu erklären, dass man auch als ahnungsloser Interessierte mitfolgen kann,
ist ja immer, keine Ahnung zu haben.
Und das fällt mir heute ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schwer, weil Vorratsdatenspeicherung
ist was, das schon wirklich sehr,
sehr, sehr häufig vorgekommen ist und wo sehr häufig schon erklärt wurde,
warum das keine gute Idee ist und trotzdem kommt es immer wieder,
also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Zombie oder Wiedergänger ist sozusagen
ein Meme, was eng damit verknüpft ist.
So jetzt nochmal ganz kurz, ich versuche jetzt mal das zu erklären,
was Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist, dann könnt ihr mir sagen, ob ich das richtig gesagt habe oder nicht.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist, wenn Leute im Internet unterwegs sind,
dass man Daten darüber speichert, was sie da machen und zwar von allen immer.
Und das sagt noch nichts darüber aus, welche Daten da gespeichert werden.
Also man könnte sich auch eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorstellen,
wo einfach wirklich alles gespeichert wird.
Aber das gibt es als Gesetzeskonzept. Und da sagt es, dass nur,
in Anführungszeichen, sogenannte Metadaten gespeichert werden sollen.
Also welcher Anschluss macht wann, von wo, was, wie lange?
Also von welchem Ort zum Beispiel wurde angerufen?
Also Telekommunikationsvorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja tatsächlich.
Ist das so richtig oder habe ich was vergessen? Oh, schon einige. Na, sag mal.
Erstens muss man vergessen, wo das gespeichert wird.
Denn diejenigen, die diese Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen erbringen...
Das käme hinterher, aber okay. Will ich mal durchgehen lassen?
Ich würde sagen, im Grundsatz schon richtig.
Im Grundsatz schon richtig, okay. Dankeschön.
Aber natürlich kann man das auch noch ausführlicher erklären.
Genau, es geht ja erstmal nur darum, was anfällt.
Das andere sind ja schon detaillierte Ausprägungen des Ganzen.
Und das zweite Spannende ist ja, und das ist dann auch immer wieder Thema,
also weil die Frage, die du gerade gesagt hast, das wird tatsächlich gerade
gar nicht, also das wird fast nie irgendwie, weil vorher passieren so Dinge, die sind schlimm genug.
Dann ist die zweite Frage, warum will man das machen?
Man will das machen, oder die Leute, die das wollen, sagen, damit könne man
besser Verbrecher fangen.
Wenn Verbrecher böse Dinge im Internet tun, dann kann man einfach nachgucken, wo waren die da?
Also welcher Anschluss hat denn da jetzt schlimme Dinge gemacht?
Und dann kann man die verdingsen, verhaften wahrscheinlich.
Klassischerweise nur für die ganz, ganz, ganz schlimmen, bösen Dinge.
Genau, das ist schon wieder Teil dieser Telenovela.
Das ist in der Regel wie mit allen Überwachungsgesetzen so, dass man sagt,
also das wollen wir nur für die Kapitalverbrechen.
Mord, Totschlag und bildliche Darstellung von Kindesmisshandlung.
Und dann sagt man irgendwann, ja, aber eigentlich wäre schon auch geil,
wenn so Raubkopierer die illegalen Musikalben runterladen, vielleicht könnte
man da auch so ein bisschen was, genau. Das passiert da immer.
Und ich habe jetzt versucht, jetzt habe ich sehr lange darüber geredet,
dass wir das schon so lange machen, ich habe tatsächlich versucht rauszufinden,
weil ich zum ersten Mal darüber gesprochen habe in einem Chaosradio,
das liegt so lange zurück, dass die Suchmaschine in der,
in dem CMS, mit dem wir das Chaosradio betreiben, das nicht findet.
Ich bin mir sicher, da muss eine 2 vorne dran stehen, weil ich das Chaosradio
erst irgendwie Mitte der 2010er glaube ich mache.
Aber es muss schon sehr lange her sein. Was war denn eure erste Begegnung mit
der Vorratsanspeicherung?
Bei mir war das einmal die politische Diskussion, die aus Europa hierher schwappte.
Das war so um das Jahr 2005, 2006 rum.
Und konkret war dann später, also der CTC war Sachverständiger in dem ersten
Verfassungsbeschwerdeverfahren und hat bei anderen zusammen das Gutachten geschrieben.
Und das war so richtig erklärbar.
Wie kann man aus diesen Daten Profile bilden?
Also einerseits die Telekommunikations-Metadaten, da ging es auch teilweise schon um IP-Adressen.
Und vor allem damals noch die Standortdaten, die waren für einen sehr langen
Zeitraum anlasslos vor Ort zu speichern.
Das war eine Riesendebatte und auch eine Anhörung in Karlsruhe.
Und da habe ich mich natürlich sehr intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Das hat aber nie aufgehört. Ich könnte mich an keinen Zeitpunkt erinnern.
Und zwischendurch kamen viele Urteile. Und jedes einzelne Urteil hat mich natürlich
auch wieder beschäftigt.
Einmal Verfassungsgericht, aber dann auch der Europäische Gerichtshof und der
Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Lieber, wie war es bei dir? Erstes Mal vor Ort zur Abspeicherung?
Ich bin am überlegen, das war schon so häufig Thema und immer wieder da und
nein und wieder da und nein.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt auch überrascht, dass da in Frankreich,
aber da kommen wir später zu, ich weiß nicht, war das das erste Mal,
dass wir mit dem Bundesverfassungsgericht zu tun hatten?
Nee, das erste Mal waren Wahlcomputer. Wahlcomputer, stimmt.
Aber tatsächlich, also die Debatte ist ein bisschen älter, glaube ich.
Das deutsche Gericht hat ja dann erst, also da gab es ja schon eine politische
Debatte davor. Ja, das ging ja ewig hin und her und überhaupt.
Auf jeden Fall kommt die Idee eigentlich aus Brasilien. Aber du weißt sozusagen,
für dich ist es gefühlt auch ewig sozusagen.
Für mich ist es gefühlt ewig und vor allem auch die Feststellung,
dass das erstmal beschlossen wird und dann ganz lange gespeichert wird und das
ganz ewig dauert, bis Gerichte dann mal sagen, nein.
Das war so meine erste Wahrnehmung dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherei,
dass es eben einen großen zeitlichen Raum gab zwischen der Einführung und der Einkassierung.
Das ist dann bei den nachfolgenden VDS-Versuchen kurzfristiger geworden.
Aber so dieses erste Mal, dass das eingeführt wurde und dann von Karlsruhe kassiert
wurde, das hat gefühlt sehr lange gedauert, der Zeitraum, in dem das war.
Daniel, wie ist es bei dir? Erste Mal Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Ich bin, glaube ich, wenn ich das so sagen darf, einen Ticken jünger als die beiden.
Menschen da neben mir.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass, also auch sicherlich das erste große Urteil, wo es gekippt wurde,
und ich weiß noch, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eines der Themen war,
wo ich bei mir gemerkt habe,
dass das irgendwie ein Thema ist, was ich politisch spannend finde,
wo ich mir Gedanken dazu mache, wo ich mehr lese als zu anderen Themen, wo ich jetzt noch nicht,
Also jetzt weiß ich, ich arbeite zu diesem Thema Digitalisierung und Überwachung und promoviere dazu,
das ist jetzt irgendwie klar, aber damals war dieses Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung
eines der Themen, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, wo ich auch mit meiner
Familie drum gestritten habe, weil ich da noch weiß,
das haben jetzt meine Eltern damals nicht so genau verstanden,
was jetzt das ganz große Problem ist und ich habe damals gemerkt,
irgendwie ist das was, was mich...
Zumindest beschäftigt, weil
ich sage, das ist doch irgendwie komisch und sollen wir das wirklich tun?
Genau, das würde ich jetzt gleich als nächstes mit euch besprechen wollen,
weil es ist ja sehr leicht zu erklären, also was ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Man kann das beliebig kompliziert machen, aber im Grunde genommen ist das klar
und es ist auch sehr leicht zu erklären, Verbrecher fangen, voll die gute Idee,
aber es gibt eben Kritik daran und die Kritik ist zweifach und.
Liebe HörerInnen, wenn ihr sagt, Mensch, ich bin schon seit Anfang der Thelio
Nobila dabei, ich weiß das alles schon.
Ich denke, wir werden in den Shownotes ein Chapter-Mark haben und dann könnt
ihr vorsprengen zu warum hat der Europäische Gerichtshof jetzt gesagt,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist doch eine geile Idee.
Aber ich will sozusagen für Leute, die es vielleicht zum ersten Mal hören und
eine Aufrechnung brauchen, will ich es so machen.
Und ich will das vor allem deswegen auch machen, weil ich mir auch vorstellen
kann, dass es auch Menschen gibt, die denken so, Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
das kommt mir bekannt vor, da waren wir doch mal auf einer Demo.
Das war nämlich sozusagen ein Thema, da gab es die Freiheit-statt-Angst-Demo
und die ist mittlerweile zehn oder noch länger her, also schon in Jahrzehnten zu bemessen her,
das war mal ein so großes Thema, dass sich da wirklich eine breitere,
nicht alle, niemals alle, aber ein breiterer Teil der Gesellschaft damit beschäftigt
und es richtig große Demonstrationen gab.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, es gibt Menschen, die dachten, das ist das eine
Mal, wo wir über Vorratsansprechungen geredet haben.
Und sonst, ja, da stehen manchmal Überschriften, aber weiß man nicht so genau.
So und ich finde jetzt die Kritik sozusagen an der Vorratsansprechung kann man
ja zweifach machen, nämlich einerseits aus der netzaktivistischen Perspektive.
Warum ist das keine gute Idee?
Und das andere ist, klang ja schon an, es gab ja immer wieder höchstrichterliche
Urteile, die gesagt haben, nein, keine gute Idee und das würde ich dann mir
von euch auch erklären lassen.
Aber zum ersten Mal so in meinem Versuch, wieder diese Position des Nichtwissenden
einzunehmen, da kommt die Politik und sagt, Leute, wir haben voll die gute Idee,
wir fangen Verbrecher, indem wir einfach eure Kommunikationsmetadaten speichern.
Ihr habt ja nichts zu verbergen und wenn dann jemand was Böses macht,
zack, haben wir ihn sofort beim Schlawittchen.
Warum seid ihr dagegen? Wer möchte da?
Was gibt es dagegen einzuwenden? Ist doch voll die gute Idee,
so die Daten speichern und einfach reingucken.
Tatsächlich würde ich nicht sagen, dass ich prinzipiell jetzt irgendwie dagegen
bin, dass ich sage, okay, der Staat muss sich in einer digitalisierten Gesellschaft
auch weiterentwickeln dürfen in einer Strafverfolgung, muss darüber nachdenken, was so.
Ich glaube, es ist immer eine Diskussion gewesen der Verhältnismäßigkeit und
da muss man, also ist es ja auch, finde ich, wäre es ein bisschen lächerlich zu argumentieren,
naja, wenn der Staat auf einem riesigen Berg von Daten sitzen würde,
die er über Telekommunikationsunternehmen abgreifen könnte,
würde er irgendwie trotzdem nicht mehr Menschen fangen.
Natürlich ist das irgendwie klar, ein einfaches Argument, dass wenn es mehr
Daten gibt, wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr Erfolg da wäre.
Die Frage ist immer nur, wie viele...
Heiligt der Zweck die Mittel? Also ist sozusagen, dass wir über alle Leute in
der gesamten Gesellschaft für eine lange Zeit deren gesamtes Verhalten abbilden,
ist uns dieser Schaden für die Bürgerrechte wert? Nee, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Was du machst ist total interessant, weil du bist sozusagen so tief in dem Thema
drin, dass du gleich aus der Annahme heraus operierst, es ist ein Schaden für
die Bürgerrechte, wenn Dinge gespeichert werden und das müsstest du erstmal erklären.
Weil das ist, von der Grundannahme her, das ist glaube ich der erste Schritt,
den man gehen muss, wenn man neu im Thema ist.
Dass man sagt, also hier werden halt Daten gespeichert, damit kann ich verbrechen,
voll die gute Idee. Und das ist genau das, was ich erstmal wissen wollte.
Anscheinend birgt das Gefahren. Welche? Naja, wir wissen auch zum Beispiel,
seit Snowden wird sich wissenschaftlich viel stärker mit der Frage beschäftigt,
was macht es eigentlich mit uns, wenn Daten über uns gesammelt werden,
wie wirkt es sich auf unser Verhalten aus?
Und es gibt eben, also man muss ganz klar sagen, für viel menschliches Verhalten
ist es tatsächlich irrelevant. relevant.
Also es wäre total vermessen zu sagen, weil es bestimmte Überwachungsinstrumente
in unserer Gesellschaft gibt, weiß ich nicht, verhalten wir uns beim Einkaufen
anders oder beim über die Straße laufen immer anders.
Das wäre total wild. Aber was wir schon wissen ist, dass gerade bestimmte Berufsgruppen
oder bestimmte aktivistische Aktivitäten immer dann, wenn sie ohnehin schon
etwas verunsichert sind, also wenn sie ohnehin schon wissen.
Einer Grenze zur Legalität oder es ist, wir haben bestimmte,
wir wissen nicht genau, ob wir uns einen Prozess leisten könnten und so weiter.
Also wenn man eh schon so ein bisschen in der Abwägung ist, dann ist die Frage,
okay, werden hier Daten von mich, über mich gespeichert, dann ist es so ein
hemmendes Momentum in meiner menschlichen Handlung.
Das wissen wir mittlerweile relativ gut und in meinem Bereich kann man das zum Beispiel sagen,
wenn wir Recherchen machen im Journalismus, die sich zum Beispiel mit Institutionen
anlegen, wo wir dreimal überlegen, okay legen wir uns mit denen an,
welche Wege in der Recherche gehen wir, da kann man schon sagen,
okay wenn wir dann auch noch wissen, dass all das was wir tun in irgendwelchen
Datenbanken liegt und unsere Recherche wird erst in einiger Zeit veröffentlicht
werden, da gibt es einen bestimmten Zeitraum dazwischen.
Das sozusagen hebt das Risiko, dass wir Sanktionen haben oder Sanktionen bekommen.
Und die Befürchtung ist eben, dass eben nicht nur Kriminalität bekämpft wird,
sondern dass sozusagen auch gewünschtes Verhalten der Gesellschaft,
freie Meinungsäußerung und so weiter eher unterbleibt, weil wir wissen,
es gibt bestimmte Daten über uns, die sagen, was wir tun und wir möchten das nicht.
Es gibt einfach Menschen, die sagen, wenn ich weiß, dass andere mein Verhalten
nachvollziehen können, dann verhalte ich mich anders.
Da ist jetzt, da steckt dann auch wieder eine Vorname drin, vielleicht kann
das einer von euch jetzt erklären, im Sinne von, wenn diese Daten gespeichert
werden, weiß man, was ich tue.
Er macht ja zwei Argumente. Einmal ist die Profilierung, das hat er,
glaube ich, jetzt sehr deutlich klar gemacht und das ist auch immer,
immer im Kern auch aller Urteile und juristischen Überlegungen.
Der zweite ist die Verhältnismäßigkeit, das hat er jetzt auch ernannt,
auch das ist immer der Kern. Nee, nee, nee, stopp.
Ich will nur nochmal zusammenfassen, was sozusagen der Kern dieser...
Aber ich bin bei Punkt eins, ich bin auch bei der Profilierung.
Also ein wichtiges Ding im Erklären der Vorratsansprechung war ja auch immer
auf, warum ist es überhaupt gefährlich?
Vielleicht müssen wir auch das nochmal kurz wiederholen. Also jemand weiß also,
ich habe dann und dann, dort und dort, war ich im Internet oder habe jemand telefoniert?
Wieso ist das ein Profil von mir? Was kann man damit machen?
Er hat ja gerade das Beispiel von Journalisten genannt, da kann man es nennen,
man könnte auch andere Berufsgruppen nennen, aber er sagt doch,
er macht eine Recherche,
dafür benutzt er Telekommunikationsmittel und jemand anders hält jeden Schritt davon fest.
Aber sozusagen, das ist eine eingeschränkte Berufsgruppe und was bei Daniel
auch gerade durchklang war ja, im Prinzip sollte das aller kümmern, tut es aber nicht.
Also warum sollte es mich interessieren, wenn ich kein Journalist bin,
kein halblegaler Aktivist bin. Das ist das Argument, was Snowden ja auch gebracht hat.
Nur weil du vielleicht im Moment gerade nichts zu sagen hast,
ist dir trotzdem Meinungsfreiheit wichtig.
Also wir alle leben davon, dass es jetzt in meinem Bereich eine freie Presse
gibt, die kritisch berichten kann.
Wir alle leben davon, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, in dem ich meinem
Mediziner bestimmte Dinge sagen darf, ohne dass er direkt zum Arbeitgeber rennt
und sagt, der ist schwer krank und entlass den mal lieber und so weiter.
Ja, aber genau, das ist das Ding, wenn ihr sagt Profilierung,
alles was ihr redet, das klingt für mich ja so,
als Laien, da müsste ich ja eigentlich Inhalte abspeichern.
Wieso kann ich denn daher, dass jemand nur weiß, wann ich mit jemandem von wo
aus telefoniert habe, wieso weiß der dann auf einmal, was ich mache?
Das ist ja ein Zwischenschritt. Ja, natürlich. Also du könntest jetzt noch mehr
bei den Grundlagen anfangen, dir überlegen, wie genau kann ich ein Profil machen,
wenn ich weiß, wo jemand hin surft und wo jemand die Kommunikation ausübt im
allerweitesten Sinne. Genau, kannst du das mal kurz sagen?
Ja, das könnte man machen. Ich finde das aber falsch. Tut mir leid,
wenn du darauf drängst. Ich glaube, dass man Grundrechte nicht unbedingt so
defensiv behandeln muss. Wir haben darauf auch ein Grundrecht.
Und sozusagen diejenigen, die verlangen, dass sie eine bevölkerungsweite anlasslose
Vorwärtsspeicherung machen wollen, die müssen eigentlich begründen,
warum das möglich sein soll und nicht immer diejenigen, die betroffen sind.
Also das ist ja eine defensive Haltung, die kann man einnehmen.
Ich glaube, es würde vor allen Dingen das Verständnis für das Thema erhöhen,
aber okay. Nee, bloß die Argumente sind ja da.
Die Argumente sind da, aber jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, kennt sie vielleicht
nicht. Deswegen frage ich sie.
Niemand von den Befürwortern ist doch in der Position zu sagen,
es gibt keine Profile, die wir daraus bilden können.
Denn die will man ja gerade haben. Also es wird ja nicht bestritten,
dass man aus Telekommunikationsmetadaten eine sehr umfangreiche Lebensprofilierung
machen kann. Da schreitet sich ja auch keiner drüber.
Ja, aber jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, weiß vielleicht nicht,
wie das geht. Aber du magst es nicht mehr erklären, weil es schon so oft erklärt
wurde? Also ich finde es auch nur ein Argument von vielen, das hat Daniel jetzt gebracht.
Ich finde, er hat es mit einem konkreten journalistischen Beispiel auch begründet.
Wenn man ja in Recherchen einfach was sehr Plastisches in der Hand hat,
da wird halt heute ja nur noch Telekommunikation benutzt.
Aber ich finde, es gibt noch eine Reihe
anderer Argumente neben dieser Verhältnismäßigkeit in der Profilierung.
Und dennoch finde ich sie immer erst auf zweiter Ebene interessant,
weil diejenigen, die speichern wollen, müssen begründen, warum sie es wollen und nähern das rum.
Nee, aber was du machst, du führst gerade eine politische Diskussion.
Was ich gerade versuche zu fragen, ist eine Verständnisfrage.
Also ich bin auch ein bisschen überrascht, weil in der Vorbereitung wurde auch
die Frage aufgeschrieben, welche Art von Profilierung erlauben IP-Adressen.
Das ist ja, was ich gerade versuche zu verstehen.
Da werden sozusagen technische Metadaten gespeichert, die keine inhaltliche Aussage machen.
Und ihr sagt alle unisono, das ist doch ganz klar, dass da eine Profilierung stattfindet.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man keine Ahnung hat von Vorratsdaten,
dann weiß man nicht, wie das passiert.
Okay, dann lass uns doch mal darüber reden, wie man sozusagen aus IP-Adressen,
denn wir werden ja später so ein bisschen vor allen Dingen uns auf IP-Adressen
stützen, weil die Diskussion darum, dass es jetzt nur noch um Telefonate oder
Standortdaten geht, die hat sich eigentlich erübrigt.
Das wird in der Soho heute nicht mehr gefordert. Na ja, das erste ist,
glaube ich, zu verstehen, dass seit Beginn der Diskussion vor rund 20 Jahren
natürlich heute sehr viel mehr dieser Daten anfallen und dass wir anders kommunizieren.
Wenn wir also die klassische Diskussion über dynamische IP-Adressen haben,
dann ist das heute ein sehr umfangreiches Profil, weil jeder das Internet und
damit auch sozusagen IP-Adressen in der Tasche hat und sehr viel mehr online erledigt.
Und die Arten der Kommunikation haben sich auch verändert.
Klar, das ist halt auch Bezahldaten, ganz viel Kommunikation.
Im Wesentlichen hat sich die zwischenmenschliche Kommunikation sogar innerhalb
der Familie auf diese Geräte verlagert.
Da hat sich einfach eine Menge getan. Das ist die Art der Profile,
über die wir heute reden, die sich aus Metadaten der Kommunikation ergeben kann,
ist nochmal eine andere, als die vielleicht am Anfang war.
Da ist jetzt zwischendurch noch die ganze Smartphone-Revolution dabei.
Da würde ich schon sagen, da hat man heute ein anderes Level und auch eine größere
Fülle von Daten, die man auswerten kann.
Und dann ist genau die auswertungsseite die nächste die tools
um also halb automatisiert wird
der mittlerweile die gerichte auch daneben ansprechen diese daten
auszuwerten sind schon längst da früher musste dann noch jemand drauf gucken
da gab es eine form von manueller oder menschliche auswertung heute ist in der
regel software basiert das gründen unterschied also die profile können gebildet
werden also ich meine im sinne von automatisiert tut mir leid wenn ich immer
mit meinen journalistischen Beispielen komme,
aber ich glaube, da haben wir wirklich ein sehr, sehr plastisches,
welche Kraft Metadaten in der Praxis haben können.
Stell dir vor, ich mache eine Geschichte, die erscheint und darin wird deutlich,
dass ich aus dem Bundesinnenministerium,
ein Papier vorliegen hatte, was eingestuft war, was mir jemand nicht geben durfte.
Ein Beamter, der hat da mindestens mal gegen Dienstvorschriften verstoßen.
Und dann gibt es die Metadaten. Nur kurz, du meinst sozusagen in dem Bericht,
den du schreibst, da kommt dann vor, du hattest Zugriff.
Da zitiere ich exklusiv, wie man das dann so schön schreibt und man ist irgendwie
stolz und schreibt ja hier laut Plänen des Bundesinnenministeriums,
die uns exklusiv vorlesen, die wir einsehen konnten und so weiter und so fort.
So, dann sieht das Bundesinnenministerium, okay, der Moosbrugger hatte dieses
Papier vorliegen und auf unserer Seite gibt es sechs Leute, die haben darauf prinzipiell Zugriff.
Und dann würdest du sehen, okay, von diesen sechs Leuten hat eine Person sieben
Tage vor Erscheinen des Berichtes mit mir telefoniert oder hat mir ein E-Mail
geschrieben. geschrieben so.
Dann musst du nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel wissen, was wir da gesprochen haben,
dann ist zumindest mal das höchste Gut, was wir im Journalismus schützen möchten,
nämlich unsere Quellen, angegriffen.
So, weil dann muss man eins und eins zusammenzählen und das ist,
glaube ich, finde ich immer ein sehr starkes Beispiel, welche Kraft Metadaten
haben können, gerade welche, die in die Vergangenheit sehen,
wenn man sozusagen später irgendwie nochmal nachgucken will,
wer hat da mit wem was getan.
Und ich glaube, an der Stelle möchte ich noch einmal zu Teil gehen,
dann entlasse ich euch sozusagen die Profilbildungsfrage, wenn du jetzt sagst, dann weiß man,
dass jemand, dass ihr irgendwie Nachrichten ausgeschaltet habt,
das heißt dann nicht, man ist auf deinem Rechner oder auf seinem Rechner und
guckt dann die Inbox, sondern weil irgendwo abgespeichert wurde,
IP-Adresse, Innenministerium hat mit IP-Adresse Moosbroker geredet,
weiß man dann, da muss Kommunikation stattgefunden haben.
Genau, zum Beispiel. Da wollte ich drauf hinaus.
Ohne den Inhalt zu kennen, kann ich trotzdem sagen, da muss was stattgefunden
haben. Und das lässt sich dann sozusagen.
Ausweiten auf andere Lebensbereiche.
Ich würde glaube ich aber trotzdem gerne nochmal, neben diesen Punkten,
da kann man bestimmt jetzt auch noch weiter in die Details gehen,
das sind auch immer die Punkte, die von den Höchstgerichten als Gründe für die
Unions-, also Europa-Unions-Rechtswidrigkeit oder Verfassungswidrigkeit genannt wurde.
Oder ich finde, es gibt noch mehr. Das eine ist IT-Sicherheit.
Diese Daten müssen irgendwo entstehen. Das kostet Unmengen und es ist auch sehr
schwierig, die zu schützen. Also für mich ist das auch nochmal ein IT-Sicherheitsargument.
Es ist viel mehr, finde ich, als es zu Beginn der Diskussion war.
Weil wir einfach eine ganz große IT-Sicherheitskrise haben, in der wir leben, von der wir wissen.
Da brauchen wir ja nur jede Newsseite aufzuklappen. Das ist aber überhaupt kein
Argument in den gerichtlichen Sachen.
Das wird wenig angesprochen. Und dann gibt es für mich noch eine andere Ebene,
die auch mit diesem Gerichtsverfahren überhaupt nichts zu tun hat,
auch letztlich nichts zu tun hat mit den Journalisten.
Und die ist, dass diese Versteifung auf diese anlasslosen Massenspeichern jeden
Blick verstellt hat auf die Alternativen, die es gibt, die ausformuliert sind,
mit denen man Verbrecher fangen könnte und zwar in der ganzen Zeit,
in denen die sich beschweren, wen sie alles nicht fangen könnte.
Und das ärgert mich halt auch besonders, denn die gibt es, die sind ausformuliert,
die gibt es auch schon lange, teilweise die Hälfte der Zeit,
über die wir jetzt so reden, also auch schon über ein Jahrzehnt.
Aber mit diesem totalitären Denken, dass es nur geht mit einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
ist total übersehenbar und dass man längst hätte tätig werden müssen.
Und zwar im Sinne der Opfer, über die wir ja dann immer nicht mehr reden.
Und das ärgert mich unglaublich. Also für mich ist das so ein seltsamer Moment,
dass die alle mit dem Kopf durch die Wand wollen.
Ich finde, wir fallen noch ein paar mehr kleinere Argumente ein,
aber das sind so die stärksten, die mir in all der ganzen Zeit auch immer,
die werden mir immer schwerer, weil ich mittlerweile diese Vorratsdatensprechungshardliner
auch als Verbrechensbekämpfungsverhinderer sehe.
Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Argument, was in den Recherchen,
die ich jetzt zuletzt gemacht habe aus dem Bereich Pädokriminalität,
das sagt dir niemand in die Kamera aus den Behörden, aber die wissen natürlich
alle, dass in dieser Versteifung auf, wir brauchen diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
ansonsten geht gar nichts,
ist natürlich extrem viel Diskurszeit, so möchte ich es mal sagen, geblockt sozusagen.
Wenn es um Kinderschutz geht, dann geht es halt darum, wollen wir Vorratsdatenspeichern? Ja, nein.
Aber ich glaube, niemand würde sagen, es würden keine Kinder mehr missbraucht
in unserer Gesellschaft, wenn wir nur eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten. So ist es ja gar nicht.
Und das ist schon ein wichtiger Punkt, den Constanze macht, dass sozusagen wahnsinnig viel…,
Diskurszeit damit verbrannt wird, um ein so ein Thema zu streiten.
Über Alternativen wollen wir später auch noch sprechen und gleich noch über
die Technik, aber das sind sozusagen die aktivistischen Gründe, um dagegen vorzugehen.
Die Gerichte haben auch wieder gesagt, es reicht glaube ich zu sagen,
dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung letztlich auf EU-Ebene geregelt wird,
also Länder machen das immer in einer eigenen in Ausprägung,
aber der grundlegende Impuls wird immer in der EU gelegt.
Und da hat der Europäische Gerichtshof, glaube ich, bis jetzt immer gesagt,
so nee, also das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch schon, aber so,
warum? Warum haben die bis jetzt gesagt, nee?
Na, ich glaube, einen kleinen Moment sollten wir da verweilen.
Da sind einige Urteile, die eine gewisse Tendenz abbilden. Der letzte ist vom
30. April diesen Jahres.
Aber die haben halt auch schon eine Geschichte. Das ist erstmal abgesägt.
Die europäische Regelung war 2014.
Also auch schon wie ein Jahrzehnt her, wo sie einfach gesagt haben,
das ist europarechtswidrig, ihr könnt nicht einfach von der gesamten Bevölkerung aufheben.
Und danach geht so eine Art Spirale los.
Das nächste Urteil ist von 2016, was auch sehr klar sagt, die Freunde,
das ist sozusagen unverhältnismäßig. Kannst du kurz sagen, warum die 2014 gesagt haben, nein?
Na, da ist die ganze Richtlinie, also das ist ja eine europäische Richtlinie,
die die Voraussetzungsprechung in Gesamteuropa vorschreibt.
Die ist sozusagen nicht vereinbar mit den europäischen Grundwerten.
Also die ist europarechtswidrig.
Darf ich da nochmal antragen? Weil das ist eine Richtlinie.
Das heißt, müssen das dann die Länder Wort für Wort umsetzen oder gibt es da
Interpretationsspielraum für die Länder?
Also es gibt immer so zwei Varianten in der Verordnung oder die Richtlinie und
die Richtlinie bewirkt, dass alle Länder ein Gesetz machen müssen und die Verordnung
wird unmittelbar gültig und das war hier eine Richtlinie.
Das war eine Richtlinie, also das ist quasi der Anstoß, um dann in den jeweiligen
Ländern ein landesspezifisches Gesetz zu machen. Genau, und die war nichtig.
Den Unterschied wollte ich nochmal, weil da gibt es eben diese zwei Dinge in
Europa, das eine was direkt gilt und das andere, das dann quasi ein Schreibaufruf
ist. Und warum war das nicht vereinbar?
Wir haben eine Grundrechtecharta in der EU, die gibt uns sozusagen gewisse Rechte
und unter anderem eben auch das Recht privat zu kommunizieren,
also sozusagen ein Recht auf Privatsphäre, würde ich es jetzt mal nennen.
Und der Kern ist die von Daniel am Anfang schon erwähnte Unverhältnismäßigkeit,
also von der gesamten Bevölkerung. Also, um es nochmal ganz explizit zu sagen,
es gibt ein Recht darauf, privat kommunizieren zu können, eine anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Hat das Gericht gesagt, würde diesem Recht widersprechen.
Und es gibt etwas im juristischen Bereich, es gibt eine Rechtsgüterabwägung.
Also man kann Rechte einschränken, wenn es einen guten Grund dafür gibt.
Aber der Grund, der 2014 vorgebracht wurde, wir brauchen das vielleicht mal,
war nicht gut genug. Das Gericht hat gesagt, nein. Nein. So, danke.
Wobei ich das auch für einen rhetorischen Trick halte, das Ding anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung
zu nennen, weil jede Form von Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist in ihrem Kern anlasslos.
In dem Moment, wo ich anlassbezogen etwas speichere, ist es nicht mehr auf Vorrat und von allen Menschen.
Das muss man da immer im Hinterkopf behalten, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung
an sich immer ein Instrument ist, das anlasslos für alle Menschen,
auf alle Menschen abzielt.
Ich halte das aber auch für einen Trick der KritikerInnen, weil wenn man das
Wort dazu sagt, wird halt klar, dass das, was da passiert, keinen Grund hat.
Also von daher ist es, ich glaube, ich gebe dir recht, es ist ein rhetorischer
Trick, aber man kann ihn von allen Richtungen aus einsetzen.
So, also die haben halt 2014 mal gesagt so, nein. Und dann haben sie...
Und ich glaube, auch 2010 war es ja, glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
das wird Konstanze besser wissen, waren es ja vor allen Dingen irgendwie auch
so Speichersicherheitsstandards, wo sie gesagt haben, nee, also unter den Standards
geht es auf keinen Fall, weil Datenschutz ist nicht gewährt, bla bla bla.
Aber auch das Verfassungsgericht hat, glaube ich, nie gesagt,
es ist völlig ausgeschlossen, dass es eine rechtskonforme Ausgestaltung einer
Vorratsdatenspeicherung gäbe.
Sie haben auch nicht gesagt, das gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich glaube, das ist schon interessant, wenn man jetzt von heute zurückguckt,
sieht man, okay, auch der Gesetzgeber hat sich immer so ein bisschen versucht
anzunähern, sage ich mal.
Wir legen einfach wieder was Neues vor und gucken mal, was sie dann sagen und
versuchen einfach den Spielraum auszuloten mit den Gesetzen.
Also sie haben nicht gesagt, das Konzept ist illegal, sondern sie haben gesagt,
so wie ihr versucht habt, das umzusetzen, das geht so nicht.
Genau. Und haben sozusagen offengelassen, ob es irgendwie anders ginge,
weil es ist auch nicht die Aufgabe von Gerichten.
Also haben natürlich... Konz hat Gefühle dazu? Ja, naja, das ist natürlich immer richtig.
Also das kann man immer sagen. Dann werden sich Gerichte immer mit genau dem
befassen, eine gesetzliche Grundlage oder eine Richtlinie oder eine Verordnung.
Aber trotzdem muss ich schon sagen, das war eine lange Anhörung,
die hat viele Stunden gedauert in Karlsruhe und natürlich war das so,
dass es um diesen Dammbruch ging, das wurde auch so belangt.
Tatsächlich ist es damals so ein krasses Urteil gewesen, dass die unmittelbar
löschen mussten. Also man muss sich das auch mal klar machen.
Wir haben natürlich das Urteil damals sehr gefeiert, aber klar war auch,
dass wir haben das für so gefährlich erachtet, dass die Daten sofort gelöscht werden mussten.
Also wollen wir nur mal klar sein, wir haben jetzt gerade auf der EU-Ebene angefangen,
du redest aber vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das hat gegen das deutsche Gesetz
zur Vorratsansprechung, das damals schon in Kraft war, also da lagen Daten und
dann haben die nicht nur gesagt,
nee, das Gesetz ist doof, sondern auch alles, was ihr bis jetzt gemacht habt, sofort weg.
Ja, also aber ich glaube, wir können nicht die gesamte, schaffen wir nicht von
der Zeit her. Aber im Grunde genommen ist das sozusagen bis jetzt Konsens gewesen.
Und dann hätte man sich ja überlegen können, also die sagen zwar nicht explizit,
die Idee ist doof, aber sie sagen immer wieder, so wie ihr das macht, eher nicht.
Da hätte man denken können, ja gut, vielleicht geht es einfach nicht.
Aber, Überraschung, vielleicht geht es doch. Und jetzt sind wir an dem Fall,
warum wir überhaupt dieses Chaosrad heute aufnehmen.
Und da würde ich, bitte seid geduldig mit mir,
tatsächlich nochmal im Sinne von am Anfang anfallen, im Sinne von es ist ja
nicht so gewesen, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof wieder gefragt wurde, könnt ihr nochmal,
bitte hier über die Vorratsseitenspeicherung entscheiden, sondern es gibt ja
einen konkreten Fall, der dahinter steckt. Kann mir den jemand erklären?
Naja, der konkrete Fall ist auch schon alt. 2010 und kommt aus Frankreich.
Und hier haben sich vier Bürgerrechtsorganisationen aus Frankreich zusammengetan,
um gegen ein konkretes Dekret in diesem Fall vorzugehen.
Und dieses Dekret sagt, wir haben hier eine Behörde in Frankreich,
die verfolgt Fileshare, also Urheberrechts oder Urheberverwertungsrechtsignorierer.
Also Kapitalverbrechen? Ja und diese besondere Internetpolizei,
die kann halt so ein dreistufiges Verfahren machen, die sagt,
ey hier, falscher Vorsicht.
Das sagt sie ein zweites Mal, Vorsicht. Und das dritte Mal kann sie eine Strafverfolgung lostreten.
Und das kann in Frankreich sein,
eine Geldstrafe oder eine Freiheitsstrafe auch in einem schweren Fall.
Also wir reden jetzt hier um Filme runterladen. Ja genau.
Also der Verstoß gegen Urheberverwertungsrechte.
Naja und das hat halt auch sehr lange gedauert. Also man hat einen innerfranzösischen
Weg genommen, Das ist halt ein uralter Dekret.
Also 2010 ist ja wirklich eine Weile her, 14 Jahre.
Und in Frankreich gibt es auch nicht wirklich ein Verfassungsgericht,
die haben ein bisschen eine andere Rechtsstruktur.
Jedenfalls ist es dem Europäischen Gericht vorgelegt worden.
Moment mal, also das heißt Frankreich hat ein Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung
aufgrund der EU-Richtlinie und diese Behörde, die EU-Überrechtsverletzungen
verfolgt, hat also Zugriff auf diese Vorratsdaten?
Ja, für bestimmte Fälle, nämlich genau für diese Verwarnungen,
wo man ja dann über die IP-Adressen, die dann nämlich gefragt werden konnten
an die Bestandsdaten kam, wer steckt denn hinter dieser IP-Adresse,
um eben eine richtige Strafverfolgung einzuleiten.
Also weil wir vorhin den Fall hatten, es geht aber nur um dieses konkrete Dekret gegen den.
Also da geht es nur um das Dekret, diese Behörde darf die Vorratsdaten benutzen in den Fällen.
Es geht gar nicht um die Frage, ob Vorratsanspeicherung oder nicht,
sondern nur, okay, und das sozusagen hat man dann auf dem Weg durch die Gerichte
eskaliert. Das ist bei Holger Hagelandert, genau. Und das war eben jetzt, am 30. April.
Und das Interessante ist, dass halt für den speziellen Corner-Case sozusagen,
wo es nur um die IP-Adressen geht, hier eine weitere kleine Tür geöffnet wurde.
Wir können zwar jetzt nicht die ganze Historie von verschiedenen EuGH-Urteilen
zur Bevorratsdatensprechung angehen, aber die IP-Adressen sind 2016 ganz klar
als personenbezogene Daten festgehalten worden.
Und dann ist so über zwei weitere Urteile bis zu dem heutigen,
also jetzigen Urteil, die Art, wie IP-Adressen genutzt werden können,
immer weiter geöffnet worden.
Erst war das nur schwere Kriminalität, da könnte man eine Ausnahme machen,
wenn man es auf das absolut Notwendige beschränkt.
Und jetzt ist halt sozusagen eine zweite Tür geöffnet worden für Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Da könnte man IP-Adressen für eine Weile aufzeichnen. Okay, jetzt bin ich tatsächlich
verwirrt, weil jetzt muss ich das Nichtwissen nicht nur spüren,
ich habe es tatsächlich nicht.
Weil, wenn das so ist, wie du gerade beschreibst, heißt es ja,
es gab eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder es gibt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung
in Frankreich, die gibt es ja aber in Deutschland nicht. Das ist richtig,
aber hier gibt es ja auch noch andere Urteile als nur der EuGH.
Wir haben unterschiedliche gesetzliche Regelungen in Europa.
Das heißt sozusagen, in Europa, also von EU-Perspektive aus,
kann es Vorratsdatenspeicherung schon geben.
In Deutschland hat noch niemand ein Gesetz hingekriegt, dass der EU-Richtlinie
mit den Einschränkungen des Europäischen Gerichtshofs durch die Urteile bis jetzt… Hä?
Sondern? Nein, jetzt hast du glaube ich mehrere Denkfehler. Die alte EU-Richtlinie
ist 2014 bereits gekippt worden, die ist nichtig.
Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass die nationalen Gesetze, die gemacht wurden in
der Zeit, dann alle... Naja genau, aber ich versuche zu verstehen,
warum Frankreich jetzt Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat, aber Deutschland nicht.
Weil sie ein Gesetz haben dafür.
Und weil sie finden, dass Filesharing echt ein Problem ist. Und wieso hat Deutschland das nicht?
In Deutschland haben wir auch ein Gesetz. Hätte die Union in Deutschland eine
absolute Mehrheit auf Bundesebene, hätten wir wahrscheinlich auch eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
weil sie… Konz schüttelt den Kopf.
Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung steht aktuell im Gesetz? Genau, ja,
aber sie wurde ausgesetzt, das muss man schon fairerweise sagen,
aufgrund dieser ganzen rechtlichen Prozesse.
Aber nur weil ein Gericht sagt, ihr könnt es nicht machen oder ihr könnt es
machen, muss es ja nicht automatisch ein Gesetz, also eine politische Mehrheit
dafür geben, es auch zu tun.
Das ist ja im Moment in der Ampelregierung auch so. Ja, das finde ich tatsächlich
sozusagen ein bisschen überraschend, weil der letzte,
die letzte politische Befürworterin der Fahrradseinsprechung,
mit der ich gesprochen habe, das ist jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre
her, war die innenpolitische Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion.
Damals in der Großen Koalition. Also von daher hätte ich tatsächlich gedacht,
wenn das in Deutschland geht, dann gibt es das auch. Also nochmal,
habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Die Richtlinie, aufgrund derer Vorratsanspeicherungsgesetze in den Ländern erlassen
werden können, ist gekippt.
Es gibt momentan keine EU-Richtlinie. Aber die bereits bestehenden Gesetze in
den einzelnen Nationen existieren nach wie vor.
In Frankreich tatsächlich auch aktiv im Einsatz, zum Beispiel für die bösen Fallscherer.
In Deutschland gibt es ein Gesetz, das das eigentlich erlaubt,
aber das ist ausgesetzt worden. Ja, und zwar aus zwei Gründen.
Auch da gibt es ein EuGH-Urteil, was sozusagen von Deutschen angestoßen wurde.
Das ist von 2020 wiederum. Und es gibt ein höchstrichterliches Urteil hier in
Deutschland vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Deswegen ist die Vorratensprechung insbesondere für zwei Provider,
die sich darum gekümmert haben, nämlich SpaceNet und die Deutsche Telekom, nicht möglich.
Denn die haben sozusagen einen höchstrichterlichen Beschluss vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht
und die haben das EuGH-Urteil erstritten. Aber wir haben ein paar mehr Provider hier.
Das heißt, die anderen Provider, die es hier gibt in Deutschland,
die diese Dienstleistung erbringen und IP-Adressen an ihre Kunden geben,
die können eigentlich jetzt nach dem 30.
April mit einer anderen Rechtslage zu tun haben. Jetzt könnte zum Beispiel die
zuständige Behörde, das ist in Deutschland die Bundesnetzagentur,
kommen und sagen, hör mal zu, das ist hier geltend recht, hier steht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
in unserem Gesetz, bitte speichern Sie jetzt.
Das ist möglich. Aber warte mal, also Telekom und Spacenet müssten das auch
nach wie vor nicht machen, weil die für sich selbst sozusagen das Urteil erstritten haben.
Alle anderen. So, was mich jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt ist, diese Schlagzeilen
zu diesem EuGH-Urteil waren ja in der Regel, Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist jetzt erlaubt.
Aber, du schützt den Kopf, aber das waren die Schlagzeilen sozusagen,
also die öffentliche Wahrnehmung davon. Aber das stimmt eigentlich gar nicht. Korrekt.
Das kann man so sagen, ja. Der Dammbruch ist also nicht so sehr,
dass Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt erlaubt ist, sondern dass man es auch für
File-Sharing benutzen kann?
Die Grenze ist runtergesetzt worden, also von schwerer Kriminalität auf alltägliche Fälle.
Denn Fasering ist alltägliche, nicht schwere Kriminalität.
Aber dieser Dammbruch zu sagen, dass im Falle von IP-Adressen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
überhaupt möglich ist, die ist nicht aus diesem Jahr, sondern eben ja schon mehrere Jahre alt.
Ich habe eine Frage aber an dich, Konstanze, müssen wir jetzt nicht fairerweise sagen.
Das ist ja in Deutschland, das ist zumindest Quick Freeze, werden wir gleich
wahrscheinlich darüber sprechen, aber dass es zumindest beschlossen wurde.
Damit wurde doch die Regelung zur Vorratsstandspeicherung.
A. Leider auch nicht. Es gibt eine Einigung über QuickFreeze,
die sozusagen... B. Ich sage es kurz.
QuickFreeze, Alternativkonzept zur Vorratsansprechung, erläutern wir später
noch genauer. A. Tun wir.
Es soll eine Einigung in der Ampel gegeben haben, die ist im Spitzengespräch
erfolgt, aber sie hat leider einen Pferdefuß und der beinhaltet,
dass die eigentliche Vorratsansprechung, die ja noch im Gesetz ist,
jetzt nicht gestrichen werden soll, sondern bestehen bleibt.
Quasi als zwar nicht so richtig genutzte, weil ja ausgesetzte,
aber eben als gesetzliche Regeln bestehen bleibt.
Und da kommt dann natürlich das Bundesinnenministerium und sagt,
ja, bei IP-Adressen sehen wir alles ein bisschen anders.
Und das haben die auch sofort getan am Tag nach der sogenannten Einigung,
haben gesagt, IP-Adressen sind nicht umfasst.
Das wäre natürlich auch möglich, denn die gesetzliche Regelung ist ja da.
Also das heißt sozusagen, es gäbe so eine Art kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung
im Sinne von, da stünden nicht alle Metadaten drin, sondern nur IP-Adressen?
Und mit Zeiträumen oder was?
Derzeit ist tatsächlich die politische Forderung seitens des Innenministeriums
dann nur um die IP-Adressen.
Niemand, also zumindest das ich es wahrnehmen würde, die Telekommunikationsdaten
oder Standortdaten jetzt derzeit ansprechen.
Das heißt, das trifft dann auf Mobilfunknetze nicht zu, weil sich da sehr viele
User einzelne IP-Adressen teilen?
Nein, technisch sprechen ist eine andere Frage. Dazu müssen wir vielleicht auch
nochmal im Detail jetzt mal kommen.
Genau, das machen wir später noch, aber nur die eine kleine Frage noch,
also IP-Adressen und Zeiträume oder nicht?
Weil man kann die ja nicht... Ja, wir haben das jetzt immer sehr verkürzt dargestellt,
denn tatsächlich geht es längst nicht mehr nur um die IP-Adressen,
das war eigentlich schon früher nicht so, sondern zu den IP-Adressen braucht
man natürlich auch gewisse Begleitdaten, insbesondere Ports,
um damit was anfangen zu können.
Denn letztlich, der Versuch ist ja immer über die IP-Adresse...
Okay, warte, ich habe euch durchgehen lassen, dass wir IP-Adressen nicht mehr
erklären, aber wenn du Ports sagst...
Dann sollten wir darauf nochmal im Detail eingehen. Ja, nicht im Detail, sondern nur ganz kurz.
Also IP-Adressen sozusagen ist ja der Anschluss und Ports sind,
könnte man sagen, die Dienste, die drüber laufen?
Also man kann erkennen, ob es E-Mail ist oder Webbrowsing?
Na, in dem Moment, wo sich wegen der Adressknappheit viele Nutzer eine IP-Adresse
teilen, also eine öffentliche IP-Adresse, wie in einem Mobilfunknetz heutzutage
üblich, da hat ja kein Telefon mehr eine öffentliche V4-Adresse bei V6,
aber... Anderes Thema. Anderes Thema.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich ein eigenes Kabel, gibt es bestimmt ein eigenes Kabel hierzu.
Genau, teilen sich mehrere Telefone eine IP-Adresse, also eine Adresse,
die von außen wie eine Adresse aussieht.
Das heißt, man kann anhand der Adresse, die man von außen sieht,
die einen Server sieht, wenn eine Verbindung aus dem Mobilfunknetz kommt.
Nicht einzelne Telefone auseinanderhalten.
Dafür braucht man dann den entsprechenden Port, weil eine Verbindung hat,
Einen von 65.000 Ports sucht man sich da aus, um sich zu dem Server hin zu verbinden.
Und es gibt Equipment beim Mobilfunknetzbetreiber, das eben diese Ports von
den Telefonen auf diese öffentliche IP-Adresse umsetzt und sich auch zumindest
für den Zeitpunkt, wo diese Verbindung steht zwischen dem Mobiltelefon und dem Server,
die Zuordnung eben zwischen einem spezifischen Endgerät und einem spezifischen
Server im Internet speichert.
Und da ist jetzt die Frage, wie lange hebt man diese Daten im Netz auf?
Weil technisch braucht man sie nur, solange die Verbindung steht.
In dem Moment, wo die Verbindung abgebaut ist, wo der Datentransfer beendet
ist, gibt es technisch für die Leistungserbringung keinerlei Grund mehr,
diese Daten aufzuheben.
Passiert natürlich trotzdem, weil man nachvollziehen möchte,
wenn sich Menschen in dem Mobilfunknetz missbräuchlich verhalten,
also auch aus Sicht des Mobilfunknetzbetreibers das Netz belasten,
was auch immer, möchte man das nachvollziehen können.
Eine ganze Zeit lang war das auch noch relevant für die Abrechnung. Genau.
Und das ist heutzutage ja nicht mehr so.
Also weil es darum ging, rauszufinden, wer wie viele Daten verbraucht hat. Richtig, genau.
Und das auch nachweisen zu können. Ich will es mal kurz sagen,
ich bin mir mal unschuldig, die Behörden, wie viel Fachwissen vielleicht doch dabei ist.
Also unter IP-Adressen können sich vermutlich die meisten was vorstellen.
Ich will eine Analogie für dieses Port-Ding machen, die ein bisschen hinkt,
wahrscheinlich nicht erschlagen, aber da kann man sich vielleicht gut vorstellen.
Ist ein bisschen, also so wie es hier benutzt wird bei diesem Geräteteil im
Mobilfunknetz, kann man sich vielleicht ein bisschen wie nebenstellen in der Telefonanlage.
Also man ruft eine große Institution an, die hat eine Telefonnummer und wenn
ich das von außen sozusagen betrachte, sehe ich nur, okay.
Markus hat jetzt irgendwie seine Krankenkasse angerufen, aber wenn ich die Nebenstellennummer
weiß, also welches spezifische Gerät in dem Netz, dann weiß ich sozusagen sehr
genau mit welcher Person er gerät.
Der Vergleich hinkt, er ist nicht eins zu eins übertragbar, aber um sich vielleicht vorzustellen.
Man könnte auch sagen nicht nur straße und hausnummer sondern vielleicht
auch die wohnungslage oder so er stimmt auch klar sehr gut
okay das sagen also
das ist das was man heutzutage speichern will
ich will dann noch mal vielleicht wenn man den
bezug nochmals von dem urteil diesen adressen und diesen zu sagen wir ganz gerne
sogar noch mal so weit vor zu zurückgehen dieses dieses französische gesetz
noch mal dieses hdp gesetz was wir glaube ich auch vom namen ja noch gar gar
nicht benannt haben, das wird dem einen oder anderen noch was sagen.
Das ist 2008 in Frankreich verabschiedet worden und hat die Idee,
dass man Urheberrechtsverstöße mit einem Three-Strikes-System handelt.
Also das ähm.
Menschen, die urheberrechtlich sich im Internet fehlverhalten.
Verdächtigt werden, man weiß es ja nicht. Also es ist ja natürlich nur ein Verdacht.
Von ihrem ASP oder von der Behörde? Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Aus der Behörde. Okay, es ist also diese Autorität pour la diffusion des oeuvres
et la protection de droite d'auteur de l'Ontarnet.
Gesundheit. Okay. Steht da in der Wikipedia.
Also die Behörde zum Schutz der Rechte von geistigen Eigentümern im Internet.
Genau, die schicken dann bis zu drei Briefe und danach soll dem Menschen,
der den Internetanschluss da hat,
für zunächst 14 Tage das Internet gekappt werden.
Das haben sie dann irgendwann wieder einkassiert. einkassiert, war das eine.
Unproportionale verhältnismäßige Einschränkung. Ich weiß gerade nicht, wo wir gerade hingehen.
Eine unverhältnismäßige Einschränkung, nur um das Gesetz nochmal zu erklären,
also um was es da eigentlich geht, also wofür diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung
an der Stelle verwendet wird.
Nämlich eben um konkret dieses eine Ding, eben die Verwarnung dieser Three-Strikes-Regel
und das Kappen des Internetzugangs und dass es ausschließlich darauf beschränkt
ist, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Das ist bei so einem Gesetz, glaube ich, auch immer der Punkt,
dass in dem Moment, wenn das Scope, wo dieses Gesetz geht, möglichst klein ist
und das wirklich nur für diesen einen Fall und diese ein, zwei konkreten Auswirkungen hat,
ist es wesentlich einfacher zu verargumentieren, dass man diese Daten speichert,
weil dann klar ist, die werden nur dafür verwendet.
Ich will den Bezug nochmal herstellen.
Der Bezug ist die Profilierung, über die wir ganz am Anfang geredet haben.
Denn das Urteil macht ganz klar, dass es nur dann möglich ist,
für diese Urheberschutzrechte die IP-Adressen aufzuzeichnen,
wenn es zu keiner Profilierung von diesen Menschen kommt.
Und deswegen ist diese Darstellung des Verfahrens, wie das in Frankreich ist, besonders wichtig.
Denn das ist so strukturiert, dass wir eigentlich zu einer Profilierung nicht kommen können.
Weil eure ursprüngliche Aussage war ja, wenn Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dann Profilierung.
Jetzt sind wir ungefähr 40 Minuten später und jetzt höre ich,
man kann Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen ohne Profilierung.
Ich bin verwirrt. Das ist, was auch in diesem Urteil steht. Das ist nämlich
so ein spezifischer Fall für diese bestimmte Behörde, die in so einem halbautomatisierten
Three-Strikes-Verfahren nur gegen Falscher hervorgeht, dass die sagen,
könnte man machen, wenn es nicht zu dieser Profilierung kommt.
Dazu müssen die aber ein paar Änderungen machen.
Warte mal, warte mal, stopp. Wir leben da jetzt aber auch in einer idealen Welt.
Ich muss das verstehen. Also, der EuGH hat gesagt.
Diese Behörde darf Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das dürfen sie sowieso,
die darf die Daten benutzen, wenn sie sicherstellt, dass die Daten,
die sie benutzt, nicht zu einer Profilbildung führen.
Deshalb, wenn ich das übersetze, heißt das, es gibt in Frankreich Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Hätte man Zugriff auf die Gesamtheit dieser Datung, auf die Gesamtheit dieser
Vorratsdaten, wäre Profilbildung möglich.
Die Behörde darf sich aber immer nur so viel Daten nehmen, für einen konkreten
Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich,
und muss sie dann wieder wegwerfen oder was auch immer sozusagen,
aber sie dürfen sozusagen sie dürfen also nicht, jetzt habe ich verstanden,
sie dürfen nicht so viele Daten abrufen aus dem Berg der Vorratsdaten,
dass eine Profilbildung möglich ist.
Ich will nur kurz verstehen sozusagen, das heißt die grundsätzliche aktivistische
Kritik an der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gilt aber in Frankreich,
weil die haben einen Datenberg, der für jeden, der darauf Zugriff hat,
Profilbildung ermöglichen würde.
Die leben da in einer scheinbar idealen Welt, wo dieser Datenberg für einen
sehr konkreten, sehr eingeschränkten Zweck nur nutzbar ist.
Allerdings müssen sie es ein bisschen anders machen, denn das ist tatsächlich
ein halbautomatisiertes Ding.
Und der Gerichtshof hat jetzt gesagt, naja, damit keine genauen Schlüsse auf
das Privatleben gezogen werden können, müssen da ein paar Änderungen kommen.
Also die brauchen zum Beispiel für den letzten von diesen drei Schritten,
brauchen die jetzt eine Form von unabhängiger Prüfung und auch eine Form von
Nicht-Automatisierbarkeit.
Also das heißt, die haben tatsächlich auch ein paar Einschränkungen für diese
spezielle HADOPI-Verfahren festgelegt.
Und jetzt musst du den Übersprung aber noch machen, wir sind noch nicht fertig mit dem Erklärmodell.
Worüber wir eigentlich ja geredet haben, ist, was so fies und böse an der Idee
von einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist.
Und jetzt stell dir mal all die Fälle vor, über die wir eigentlich immer reden
bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das ist nämlich nicht so eine spezielle Behörde, die die Bestandsdaten für Fileshare
abrufen will, sondern das ist in der Regel Strafverfolgung.
Und der Übertrag ist halt verdammt schwer. Überhaupt, wenn man sich das urteilt,
das ist natürlich auch sehr lang und komplex durchliest, dann kann man sich
eigentlich nicht vorstellen,
wie diese Nicht-Profilierung, die drinsteht, es darf keine genauen Schlüsse
auf das Privatleben geben, wie die übertragbar wäre auf eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde,
die auf IP-Adressen, anlasslos gespeicherte IP-Adressen zugreifen kann.
Ich wiederhole jetzt im Prinzip, was du gesagt hast, obwohl ich es so schnell nicht verstanden habe.
Das Urteil sagt, die Behörde darf sozusagen, muss das minimale Datenset,
sagen wir mal, abrufen, damit eben keine Profilbildung stattfinden kann.
Und du sagst jetzt, also, wenn man das jetzt zum Anlass nimmt und denkt,
ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht vielleicht doch, wie können wir das machen?
Wenn man das einsetzen wollen würde für eine Strafverfolgung,
dann müsste man, damit es für die Strafverfolgung sinnvoll ist,
so viele Daten abrufen, dass dann automatisch quasi mehr oder weniger ein Profil entsteht.
Ich glaube eigentlich, dass dieses Urteil keine Tür öffnet für alles,
was in Deutschland an IP-Adressen, Anlasslosspeicherung überhaupt diskutiert
wird, weil wir ja diese Form von Verfahren gar nicht haben.
Na, aber was ich total spannend finde, ist sozusagen für jemanden.
Der sich jetzt nicht alltäglich mit Vorratsanspeicherung beschäftigt,
sondern der sozusagen so oft wie im Chaos, also jedes Mal, wenn wir im Chaos
gerade drüber reden, sozusagen sich damit beschäftigt, ist für mich,
Also das klang schon vorhin an, wo du über die ganzen Urteile gesprochen hast,
ist für mich sozusagen anscheinend in den letzten Jahren passiert,
dass wir uns gar nicht mehr dagegen wehren, dass es Vorratsdatenspeicherung
gibt, sondern nur noch dagegen, wofür die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdaten,
die anfallen werden, wofür die verwendet werden.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Die sind schon sehr, sehr unglücklich,
die französischen Aktivisten.
Das haben die auch sehr klar geäußert. Die hätten sich einen Sieg gewünscht
und die empfinden das auch nicht als Sieg. Und Sieg wäre gewesen?
Das natürlich nicht erlaubt wird, auf die anlasslose IP-Adressen Vorratsdatenspeicherung zuzugreifen.
Aber selbst der Sieg wäre, hätte ja nicht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung angegriffen.
Nein, die haben ein Dekret angegriffen, aber bisher war die Grenze schwere Kriminalität
und Falschschäuung ist keine schwere Kriminalität und insofern ist das… Aber
das unterstreicht ja meinen Punkt.
Es geht gar nicht mehr darum, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu verhindern,
sondern es geht nur noch darum, zu verhindern, dass auf die Daten,
die eh schon da sind, zugegriffen wird. In Frankreich würde ich das politisch
wahrscheinlich so sehen.
Und ich finde, wenn man Konstanze folgt und eben ganz nah am Urteil bleibt,
kommen wir dann zu paradoxen Situationen.
Wenn wir es mal auf Deutschland übertragen, dann könnte es sein,
dass du eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hast, um Filesharer verfolgen zu können.
Aber ein BKA sagt dann, ja, aber irgendwie Cybercrime können wir nicht bekämpfen,
weil wir haben ja keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die Kinder können wir auch
nicht schützen, weil wir haben auch keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Und das wäre ja jetzt nicht juristisch argumentiert. Entschuldigung,
da bin ich sozusagen total empfindlich, deswegen muss ich jetzt mal sagen,
du zittierst, also du channelst gerade das BKA, niemand schützt Kinder durch
Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich wollte nur sagen, also ein Kernargument ist ja immer,
dass sozusagen viele Straftaten im Bereich der Pädokriminalität,
das ist nicht nur das BKA, das ist auch die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt
und Bamberg und Köln, dort sind so die drei Schwerpunktstaatsanwaltschaften
in Deutschland, die dazu arbeiten, die sagen schon sehr, sehr klar,
wir brauchen dieses Argument Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
um hier in der Quote der Täteridentifizierung massiv nach vorne zu kommen.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist was anderes.
Wir hätten dann eine politische Diskussion, wo es so wäre,
und das kannst du ja den normalen Leuten draußen nicht erklären,
wir dürfen auf diese Daten zugreifen, um irgendwelche Raubkopierer abzumahnen,
aber wir dürfen nicht darauf zugreifen, um schwere Kriminalität zu bekämpfen.
Das ist ja politisch ein Wahnsinn.
Ich bin jetzt aber schon wieder, ich lerne ja jede Menge Dinge zu sagen.
Das heißt, es ist unumstritten, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung bei der Fassung
von Leuten, bei der Festnahme von Leuten hilft, die….
Nein, unumstritten ist das nicht, aber es ist sozusagen aus,
also es ist einfach, also aus Sicht einer Strafverfolgungsbehörde ist das unumstritten,
so würde ich es mal sagen.
Also die machen schon sehr stark das Argument, wir brauchen das ansonsten,
oder sie sagen, es ist eines der zentralsten Bedürfnisse, die wir im Moment haben.
Da kann man dann die Dimensionen aufmachen,
wie lange brauchen wir die Daten, wie lange speichern wir die Daten,
weil da gibt es dann das Kontinuum zwischen einer mehrere Monate langen Datensammlung
bis hin zum besagten Quick-Freeze, den wir an der Stelle vielleicht mal erklären können.
Jetzt wollt ihr bestimmt wissen, was im EuGH-Urteil steht zu den zeitlichen Dimensionen, oder?
Wollt ihr doch bestimmt wissen. Nee, ich glaube jetzt, sondern weil was wir
immer machen, wir fassen immer so kurz die Technik an und dann gehen wir zu
einem Punkt, vielleicht machen wir jetzt sozusagen, erklären wir das mal.
Was bedeutet Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich technisch? Weil da kann man
hinterher auch sehr gut drüber sprechen, wie lange, weil wenn es technisch Ressourcen
verbraucht, die potenzieren sich ja je länger man das macht und so weiter und so fort.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was bedeutet das technisch? Was machen die denn da
eigentlich? Was machen die da eigentlich? Was ist da los? Setzt sich da jemand
hin und schreibt die IP-Adressen in ein großes Buch? Ja.
Gut, das war einfach weiter. Nein. Im Wesentlichen, ganz abstrakt,
ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung die Speicherung von Begleitumständen der Kommunikation,
also Metadaten, in Zuordnung zu einer Person oder einem Vertrag an der Stelle. Ja.
So ein Internetzugang ist ja in der Regel nicht eine Person,
sondern ein konkreter Vertrag.
Man hat eine SIM-Karte oder eine eSIM, mit der man sein Telefon...
Wer jetzt das Telefon dann genau verwendet hat, steht nicht dran,
aber es ist halt der Kunde bekannt.
Dasselbe für Internetanschluss zu Hause. Da ist ja auch nicht der jeweilige
Kunde, sondern dann haben wir Dinge, die sind personengebunden,
wie beispielsweise ein E-Mail-Account in der Regel.
Da gibt es halt ein großes Kontinuum an Daten, die anfallen,
rund um die Kommunikationsvorgänge, die man dann an den jeweiligen Anschlüssen
tätigt, die Internetseiten, die man abruft, Mails, die man irgendwo hinversendet.
Das gelegentlich dann doch auch mal ein Telefonat von einer Telefonnummer an eine andere passiert.
All das sind Daten, die man auf Vorrat sozusagen speichern kann,
um da dann, wenn man die Frage hat, wer hat wann mit wem E-Mails ausgetauscht,
telefoniert, ist auf welche Internetseiten gegangen, hat,
in welchen Chaträumen, in wo auch immer.
Sei es IRC oder was auch immer.
Nicht bei langer ICQ. Nicht bei langer ICQ.
Eben kommuniziert, also da geht es um um das Wer-Wann-Mit-Wem.
Genau, aber wie ist das zum Beispiel technisch? Also weil das sind ja alles
Daten, die braucht man im Moment der Kommunikation tatsächlich,
um die Kommunikation durchzuführen.
Und ist das dann so, es gibt also ein technisches System, das sorgt dafür,
dass diese Kommunikation stattfinden kann und dann sind die Daten,
die Daten fallen also eher an einem Zeitpunkt der Kommunikation.
Ist es dann so, dass man sagt, okay, die bleiben hier drin und wir löschen die einfach nicht?
Oder ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung schon so geregelt, dass man sagt,
okay, du hast die Daten und deswegen speicherst du die bitte in einem Vorratsdatenspeicherungssystem?
Also ich frage mich jetzt auch sowas wie, wenn die Behörden Zugriff wollen,
kriegen die Zugriff zu einem technischen System oder müssen die eine Information
bei den Telekommunikationsanbietern anfragen?
Da sind wir bei der technischen Realisierung und das ist tatsächlich technisch
relativ involviert, weil in so einem Kommunikationsnetz es sehr viele Systeme
gibt, wo diese Daten anfallen.
Sei es jetzt die Kommunikationsdaten an sich oder auch Standortdaten.
Es gibt ja alles Mögliche an Daten, die temporär, also vorübergehend in einem
Netz anfallen, die man dann aber auch festhalten und speichern kann.
Und da gibt es Anbieter, die Systeme anbieten, die man sich als Netzbetreiber in sein Netz hinstellt.
Die bekommen dann Schnittstellen an alles Mögliche, was man so in seinem Netz
hat, an alle möglichen Komponenten, die eben mit diesen Begleitumständen der
Kommunikation zu tun haben.
Das ist eben nicht nur der eine oder andere Router, sondern da geht es dann
auch darum, wo hat sich eine Person aufgehört oder wo hält sich eine Person
mit einer SIM-Karte in einem Netz auf.
Das alles sind Optionen, die
man von diesen Anbietern dieser Speicherlösungen sich dazu buchen kann.
Und die haben andererseits dann auch wieder, werben sie sogar damit,
dass sie mit den Strafverfolgungsbehörden und mit den Bedarfsträgern, nennt man das, also ….
Institutionen im Staat, die einen Bedarf an diesen Daten haben,
dass sie damit hervorragende Beziehungen haben und auch die Schnittstellen und so weiter.
Also dass wenn irgendwie eine solche Behörde anfragt, die sich freuen,
wenn dieses und jenes Produkt eingesetzt wird, weil da wissen sie, okay, da verhalten,
sich die Schnittstellen kompatibel mit den Systemen, die sie da zur Abfrage
verwenden also das ist ein produkt was man sich einkaufen kann von mehr als
einem hersteller auch wenn es da einen großen gibt er das macht die sind standardisiert
ist natürlich sehr wichtig und das ist standardisiert.
Kurze frage ist das so ich kaufe ein produkt hänge das bei dir bei mir rein
und dann kontrolliere aber ich erzähle kommunikationsanbieter das produkt oder
sind die dann noch als dritter das ist sogar so dass das cloud lösung dass du
du als Telekommunikationsanbieter,
du brauchst das ja auch für Lawful Interception, also für Abwehrschnittstellen,
weil da ist ja auch der, die, die… Das hört sich an wie ein Trojaner,
den ich mir da einbaue. Ja, aber einer, der zertifiziert ist.
Der hängt schon, also das sind schon Geräte in den internen Netzwerkstrukturen
natürlich, aber die sind auch vorgeschrieben.
Also du kannst ja als deutscher großer Provider natürlich nicht sagen… Nee,
aber nochmal, wer administriert dieses Gerät?
Tut das der Telekommunikationsanbieter selber oder tut das die Firma,
die das Gerät zur Verfügung stellt?
Das tut in der Regel die Firma, die das Gerät zur Verfügung stellt.
Die beauftragst du damit, dass sie das Gerät dahin stellt.
Die beauftragst du damit, dass sie das Gerät anpasst oder die Geräte anpasst und mit...
Denen und deinen Technikern im Haus guckt man dann, dass man das eben integriert.
Und das ist sogar so weit, dass bei Abhörmaßnahmen du als Netzbetreiber gar
nicht erkennen können darfst.
Erkennen können darfst. Also es muss dir unmöglich sein zu erkennen,
welcher deiner Anschlüsse zu welcher Zeit von welchem Bedarfsträger abgehört wird.
Also natürlich manche Bedarfsträger, namentlich Geheimdienste zum Beispiel,
die müssen nicht gegenüber oder die dürfen nicht bekannt sein gegenüber demjenigen,
der die Kommunikationsdienstleistung erbringt. Die Firma, die das Gerät, die weiß das schon.
Also ich will nur so sagen, auf der aktivistischen Ebene heißt das,
also es gibt hier einen Datenberg, der grundrechtsrelevant ist und auf die nicht
nur der Telekommunikationsanbieter, der es ja meistens eh weiß,
weil er es für die Technikabteilung braucht, und auch nicht die Behörden,
die Strafverfolgung gehören, sondern auch noch eine dritte Partei,
nämlich die, die die Technik zur Verfügung stellt.
Ich glaube, wir dürfen jetzt aber auch nicht, glaube ich, generalisieren,
dass das immer überall so ist.
Also mir sind auch Fälle bekannt, dass durchaus Strafverfügungsbehörden zu irgendwo
hingehen und sagen, hey, dieser Anschluss hier, da brauchen wir das, leite uns das mal aus.
Ich glaube, es kommt auch ein bisschen auf die Größe des Unternehmens an, oder?
Durchaus, ja. Aber da, wo das eben automatisiert ist, also ich kenne es aus
den Anforderungsdokumenten, ist eben immer darauf geachtet, dass wenn das automatisiert passiert,
dann ist der Personenkreis, die auf die Liste der aktiven Maßnahmen Zugriff hat, möglichst klein.
Idealerweise null kann man natürlich nicht, aber eben möglichst klein zu halten.
Das stimmt, aber in so einem Unternehmen wissen es wirklich sehr,
sehr wenig Leute, wer gerade überwacht wird.
Und wie teuer ist das? Ja. Naja, die haben keine Preislisten.
Nee, nee, nee, ich habe ein Missverständnis. Ich wollte keine Hausnummer haben,
sondern im Sinne von, wenn ich Telekommunikationsdienstleister bin,
betreibe ich Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur kostet Geld, das Ding kostet auch
Geld, ich will eher sozusagen so ein Verhältnis.
Also habe ich dann 100 Prozent, also verdoppelt sich mein Aufwand oder ist es
eher sozusagen so ein Peanuts oder ist es eher 10 Prozent, Also im Sinne von,
man muss schon Geld ausgeben, aber es ist schon auch verschmerzbar?
Na, ich würde schon eher sagen, das ist verschmerzbar, wenn man das nur in Geld
betrachtet. Aufwand ist aber ein bisschen mehr als nur Geld.
Naja, und das ist verschmerzbar. Also für einen Telekommunikationsanbieter ist
das schon kein Ding, was sie gerne machen, weil von dem Geld könnten sie andere
Infrastruktur oder günstigere Tarife oder was auch immer. Also für den Telco
oder Internetanbieter.
Gerade bei den geringen Margen, die es da teilweise hat, ist das schon, ja.
Gerne machen die das nicht. Also man kann sagen, es ist leistbar,
aber es fällt durchaus auch schon ins Gewicht. Genau.
Es war anfangs mal eine riesige Debatte, das liegt ja auch daran,
also die muss ich jetzt schon klar machen, in Deutschland haben sich die großen
Internetdienstleister ja auch, vor allem auch der Verband ECO, stark gemacht dafür.
Die haben die Gerichtsurteile mit erkämpft.
Der in dem SpaceNet-Fall etwa, der zum EuGH ging und der erfolgreich war,
hat sich auch der Verband hintergestellt. Also die sind jetzt keine Befürworter.
Am Anfang war das auch mal eine Diskussion, ob das überhaupt bei den Providern gespeichert wurde.
Warum das selbstverständlich sein sollte, dass die das bezahlen.
Und auch die Frage, ob die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Interessenträger denn
vielleicht pro Maßnahme auch bezahlen dürfen, dass das Equipment da steht.
Also das ist schon auch eine lange Debatte.
Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es keine Nichtdebatte ist, aber ich glaube
in unserem Kontext, wo es doch immer eher um diese gerichtliche Entscheidung
geht, um Verhältnismäßigkeit, ist es dann doch eher nicht so eine Priorität
in der Diskussion, würde ich sagen.
Technisch, du brauchst ja auch Leute und so, also das ist ja nicht nur das Equipment,
du musst es dir auch 24-7 zur Verfügung stellen, da hängt auch Wochenendarbeit
dran und so, für dich ist es das auch nicht, ne? Genau, aber dann, ja.
Ich glaube, das, was Constanze sagt, ist nochmal ganz wichtig,
dass man das auch als Hörer und Hörerin zusammenbekommt.
Bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht es immer so darum, dass der Staat sagt,
du musst das tun und du hast keine andere Wahl, weil wir verpflichten dich dazu.
Was natürlich immer wichtiger geworden ist, auch durch den Wandel der Kommunikation
in den letzten Jahren, was Constanze gesagt hat, ist, dass Strafverfolgungsbehörden
natürlich zudem auch anfragen bei Unternehmen, die gar nicht verpflichtet sind,
aber die trotzdem Daten haben.
Du hast eben das Beispiel irgendwie, E-Mails werden auseinandergetauscht,
wir alle nutzen WhatsApp und so weiter.
Auch bei WhatsApp kann natürlich eine straffe Folgungsbehörde fragen,
sag mal über diese Telefonnummer, mit wem hat der denn eigentlich irgendwelche
Nachrichten und so weiter hin und her geschrieben. Das sind auch Vorratsdaten
in dem Sinne, technisch genau gleich.
Die sind auch gespeichert, nur sozusagen, sie sind aus kommerziellen Gründen
einfach da und werden natürlich abgefragt.
Und das ist jetzt nicht Teil dieser Debatte, aber wird natürlich in der Strafverfolgungspraxis
auch sehr, sehr rege gemacht mit zunehmendem Eifer.
Und was da an Daten gespeichert werden, also das muss man sich mal klar sein,
bei WhatsApp tauscht man sein Telefonbuch gegen das Privileg,
diesen Dienstleiter zu nutzen, das heißt, dem liegt dein komplettes Telefonbuch vor in Klartext.
Ich glaube, wir gerade stehen rund beim Satz, wir alle nutzen WhatsApp.
Ich bin bekennende Nicht-Berufsführer. Das ist nicht ganz richtig,
aber es ist natürlich sozusagen megabyte. Statistisch stimmt das.
Mega, mega weit. Das Schlimme ist, ich benutze es nicht, weil ich den Deal,
mein Telefonbuch gegen eine Kommunikationsdienstleistung einzutauschen,
wo ich noch nicht meine Telefonnummer für hergeben muss, weil es gibt Streamer.
Aber selbst wenn ich das nicht nutze.
Ich kenne ja sehr viele Menschen, die meine Telefonnummer in ihrem Telefonbuch
haben, also die haben umgekehrt quasi ein Rückwärts-Telefonbuch.
Wer kennt alles diesen Nibbler und seine Telefonnummer?
Ich jetzt sozusagen letzte Frage nochmal zu diesem technischen Ding und auch
zum Budget, damit wir dann wieder zu den Speicherfristen zurückkommen ist.
Es ist also finanzieller Aufwand, der ist leistbar, fällt aber durchaus ins Gewicht.
Wie viel schlimmer wird das, wenn man es länger speichert?
Also ist zum Beispiel, wenn ich statt sechs Monate in den Jahr speichere,
ist das eine Verdopplung der Kosten
oder ist das dann so, Festplatz kostet nichts, das ist dann auch egal?
Das ist ja auch eine Funktion des Volumens, was man an Daten durch sein Netz schiebt.
Und allein auf der Basis haben wir in den letzten Jahren eine Verringerung der
gespeicherten Daten gesehen.
Also der Daten, die Netzbetreiber für Analysezwecke speichern,
um eben auch Missbrauch im Netz, also eben im Sinne von technischer Missbrauch
an Kommunikationseinrichtungen,
weil eben das Volumen auch immer mehr wird an Daten, die da anfallen.
Aber du hast die Frage nicht beantwortet.
Also wird der finanziell-wirtschaftliche Auswand relevant höher,
wenn ich die Speicherung der Metadaten verlängere?
Oder ist es, wenn es eh schon mal eingerichtet ist, dann ist sozusagen ein Mehr
an Datenfeld nicht so sehr ins Gewicht?
Also um es platt zu sagen, wenn ich mir einen Computer kaufe,
dann gebe ich da im Zweifel irgendwie sowas zwischen 1000 und 1500 Euro aus,
wenn er halbwegs aktuell ist. Wenn der nochmal eine doppelt so große Festplatte
braucht, fällt jetzt nicht mehr so richtig doll ins Gewicht.
Das ist die Frage, die ich quasi stelle. Also ist das Einrichten das Teure und
der Speicherplatz dann eher egal
oder ist längere Speicherfrist nochmal relevanter zusätzlicher Aufwand?
Naja, zunächst sind das sehr teure Computer, die man da einsetzt.
Also einer der Marktführer verbaut da meines Wissens Oracle-Server.
Da kann sich jeder selber ausrechnen, welche Preisklasse das ist und wie teuer
dann da entsprechend auch... Niemand außer dir kann sich ausrechnen,
was ein Oracle-Server kostet. Sag kurz eine Hausnummer, wenn du schon dabei
bist. Wenn du fragen musst, dann ist es zu teuer.
Wir reden hier fünfstellig? Ja. Für einen? Für einen sein wir.
Also eine hohe fünfstellige Summe. Ja, okay, gut. also dass die anschaffung
und dann wie gesagt ich kann ja jetzt keine keine keine keine zahlen nennen
aber mehr ist halt mehr und es wird immer mehr dadurch dass mir last auf den letzten aus,
also vielleicht also ich finde er hat die frage insofern beantwortet dass die,
telekommunikationsanbieter natürlich in interesse hatten diese volumen zu reduzieren
einfach weil immer teurer wird denn wir reden in den 20 jahren über univerna
verachtlich fachung des volumens Das ist ja enorm, was die Leute produzieren.
Die haben natürlich Interesse davon.
Klar. Und du musst es auch immer zusätzlich sichern. Bei längeren Zeiträumen
kannst du das nämlich nicht mehr so.
Du kannst das nicht für so einen kurzen Zeitraum irgendwo lassen,
sondern du musst dir dann echt ein Konzept machen für eine längere Speicherung. Wohin?
Unter IT-Sicherheitsbedingungen, die du zu gewährleisten hast.
Also dann ist ja auch nochmal so ein Kostenfaktor.
Also es ist schon unangenehm. Das sind ja auch nicht irgendwelche Daten,
sondern das sind Daten, auf die man möglichst aufpassen muss. Ja unbedingt.
Also gut, was ist denn jetzt mit den Speicherfristen?
Ja, wir haben ja noch gar nicht über die Speicherfristen im Urteil gesprochen.
Da habe ich natürlich, wie ihr euch das vorstellen könnt, das war das Erste,
wonach ich gesucht habe.
Und tatsächlich haben sie nichts dazu drin. Sie sagen, man muss es auf das absolut
Notwendige beschränken.
Das ist so ein Terminus, den die jetzt oft drin haben, der schon seit 2020 etabliert
wird. Das heißt, da kann man sich dann fantastisch wieder vor Gericht darüber
streiten, was das bedeutet?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich, also da steht keine Wochen oder Monate oder sonst irgendwas
drin, sondern nur das absolut Notwendige. Das ist wie so eine Art Phrase mittlerweile.
Und das war natürlich auch so ein Teil der Kritik.
Das war doch, glaube ich, das wirst du besser wissen, aber ich glaube bei dem
2010er Urteil des Verfassungsgerichtes war es doch auch so, sie haben gesagt,
sechs Monate ist zu lang, aber was, also sie haben jetzt auch nicht gesagt,
aber drei gingen oder so.
Aber das ist ja auch, da hatten sie konkret, das letzte Stand ja war,
und hier ist es ja nicht ganz so. Also, man muss, man finde,
man sollte doch nicht so den Gerichten überhelfen.
Letztlich, also, die fühlende Debatte darüber in Deutschland.
Der Gesetzgeber sollte Gesetz geben, meinst du nicht, das Gericht?
Naja, okay, dann sind wir jetzt
auf einer anderen Ebene. Das ist die erste Plenumsentscheidung des EuGH.
Plenum bedeutet, dass die große Kammer, die haben verschiedene große Kammern
bei diesem Gericht, dass die sich nicht einig wurde.
Also, sie haben das Plenum von allen 27 EuGH-Richtern für dieses Urteil herangezogen.
Das ist ein Novum. Das ist schon dick.
Da muss ich gleich so eine Detailfrage mal stellen, weil ich habe jetzt in dem,
ich habe schon die öffentliche Wahrnehmung so wahrgenommen wiederum,
dass das schon was Neues ist, was da passiert ist.
Und dann wurde auch immer darüber spekuliert, wie ist das zustande gekommen?
Und dann gibt es natürlich so, naja, also im Prinzip, wenn man sich das anguckt,
dann kann man über die Jahre schon feststellen, dass das abzusehen war,
dass das irgendwie so sagen die einen und die anderen sagen so,
naja, das hängt schon auch damit zusammen, wer beim EuGH da gerade Berichterstatter
ist, glaube ich, das richtige Wort ist.
Gab es da so eine Art Personalwechsel?
Also woran lag es, dass die jetzt quasi umgeschwenkt sind?
Dazu muss man sich, glaube ich, eins klar machen. Das eine ist,
deutschlandweit haben wir eine Debatte über die Vorratsdatensprechung.
Anderswo ist das überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Wir haben eine ganz große Mehrheit in Europa, die ja auch beim EuGH abgebildet
wird über die Rechte, die überhaupt nicht streitet über die Vorratsdatensprechung.
Das ist echt ein Unterschied.
Also ich denke, Steter Tropfen höht den Stein. Die nationalen Regierungen in
Europa haben weitgehend ignorant gegenüber den EuGH-Urteilen agiert.
In Deutschland ist das was anderes.
Aber die trommeln unablässig, obwohl es diese vielen Urteile gab.
Ich habe die vorhin genannt. 14, 16, 20 und jetzt wieder. Die trommeln wie die Blöden.
Wir haben bei Netzpolitik zum Beispiel den Diplomatenbericht öffentlich machen
können, der die Haltung der verschiedenen EU-Staaten zur Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung
darstellt. Und die wollen das alle.
Wir sind eine der wenigen Länder, wo das anders ist.
Und da muss man schon sagen, da halten die vielleicht auch nicht immer stand.
Aber trotzdem haben sie letztlich diese Tür gefunden,
Nur ein sehr, sehr kleines Stück geöffnet. Also für mich ist das Trommeln trotzdem
nicht erfolgreich gewesen.
Ich bin immer noch der Einschätzung unklar, weil du sagst, sie haben die Tür
nur ein kleines Stückchen mehr geöffnet, aber die Tür ist halt jetzt offen und
vorher war sie zu? Nein, auch schon nein.
Sie haben die Vorratsdatenspeicherung im Prinzip ja erlaubt für schwere Kriminalität,
wenn sie auf das absolut Notwendige beschränkt ist, auch schon in einem früheren
Urteil, was die IP-Adressen angeht.
Ich glaube halt, die Frage ist immer so ein bisschen, wollen wir das jetzt juristisch
bewerten oder wollen wir überlegen, was heißt das für den politischen Diskurs?
Und für den politischen Diskurs ist das glaube ich schon eines der wichtigsten
Urteile der letzten Jahre,
weil es eben nicht nur im Kern Konstanze darum geht, was steht da juristisch
für juristische Feinheiten drin,
sondern wie wird es genutzt als Argument in der politischen Diskussion.
Und schon das letzte EuGH-Urteil, wo es um schwere Kriminalität ging,
war für die Befürworter derjenigen in Deutschland, die das wollen,
die Vorratsanspeicherung wollen,
das ganz klare Argument, um die Ampel vor sich hertreiben zu können und einfach
sagen zu können, der EuGH hat gesagt, es geht.
Und auch da steht eigentlich drin, dass es nur unter sehr bestimmten Bedingungen
geht, aber es wurde dann sozusagen kommunikativ so verpackt,
hey, der EuGH sagt, es geht, ihr macht es nicht, ihr lasst also sozusagen willentlich
zu, dass Kriminalität nicht aufgeklärt werden kann.
Und das ist schon, ich glaube nicht, dass das mit dem Urteil besser wird.
Ich glaube, das wird eher mehr. Also das kannst du noch ein drittes Mal sagen,
das hat vorhin im Prinzip schon gesagt und Markus hat das auch gesagt, ich teile das nicht.
Natürlich gibt es vor den Befürwortern hier ein Interesse zu sagen,
dieses Urteil macht einen Unterschied, aber in der Sache ist es gerade kein
Dammbruch. Ich finde dieses Framing falsch, es wurde jetzt hier gemacht unmittelbar nach dem Urteil.
Ich bin mir aber auch ziemlich sicher bei den vielen Juristen,
die sich damit beschäftigen, die sich jetzt darüber beugen werden,
die teilweise auch schon die Macht haben, dass die Einschätzung ein bisschen anders sein wird.
Das ändert aber nichts an den politischen Forderungen, das stimmt schon.
Aber dann ist der Dammbruch eigentlich schon vorher gewesen,
nämlich zu sagen, ein bisschen anlasslos geht. Genau, das glaube ich auch.
Aber nicht in diesem Urteil jetzt vom 30. April. Aber das möchte ich noch einmal so sagen.
Ich möchte es noch einmal nachfragen im Sinne von, also ich verstehe das einerseits,
dass eigentlich der Dammbruch schon früher war, wenn man sagt,
also Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es so, also dann ist ja der Drops gelutscht,
könnte man sagen, weil dann geht es nur noch um die Anwendung.
Also was macht man dann damit?
Und deswegen verstehe ich sozusagen deine Einschätzung nicht ganz.
Also ich kann sie juristisch nachvollziehen, dass man sich hinschaut und sagt,
also das Urteil, das ist so eng fokussiert, da lässt sich nichts daraus ableiten.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass es eben, also selbst wenn man diese Einschätzung teilt,
würde ich denken, es gibt aber das Signal,
wenn du dich nur genug anstrengst in der Art und Weise, wie du deine Gesetze
formulierst, dann kannst du es halt für alles verwenden, wenn selbst Fallsharing geht.
Das wäre meine Angst jetzt, aber das siehst du nicht. Naja, das würde ich schon
auch so sehen, wenn ich jetzt auch diese Trommelfeuer über die Jahre und die
vielen nationalen Gesetze und so, die ja auch beschlossen wurden zwischendrin sehe.
Aber für diesen konkreten Fall stimmt es halt auch schlicht nicht,
weil das so ein uraltes Gesetz ist.
Das ist halt ein 2010er Dekret. Also trotzdem hat natürlich diese politische Trommel eine Wirkung.
Und da sitzen halt auch Vertreter von Europa, die andere Haltungen haben als
sie hier üblicherweise sozusagen im öffentlichen Diskurs sind.
Aber dennoch sozusagen die grundsätzliche Haltung ist anlassloses,
verdachtsloses, massenspeichert, europarechtskonform, da ist die Antwort immer noch nein.
Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, ja, das steht auch in diesem Urteil so drin,
du kannst sozusagen nicht einfach massenhaft bevölkerungsweit speichern,
aber sie machen halt gewisse Einschränkungen.
Sie sagen, unter diesen und jenen Umständen, wenn zum Beispiel keine Rückschlüsse
auf das Privatleben möglich sind, also keine Profilierung, kannst du das aufs
absolut Notwendige beschränkt tun.
Das ist doch ein Unterschied. Also sozusagen, woran ich scheitere,
ist sozusagen der für mich in meinem Gehirn, Entschuldigung,
noch nicht aufgelöste Widerspruch, dass man anscheinend da auslesen kann,
dass es im Grundsatz nicht okay ist, aber es passiert halt trotzdem.
Und wie das zusammenpasst, das verstehe ich nicht. Die Einschränkung ist,
wenn du in diesen Datenpool nur für einen sehr, sehr, sehr kleinen Grund automatisiert
reinschaust, dann kannst du diesen Datenpool anlegen.
Und wenn du dabei ausschließen kannst, dass es auf dieses Privatleben Einblicke
in das Privatleben der Betroffenen gibt.
Ja genau, aber du hast ja die ganze Zeit die Formulierung benutzt sozusagen,
es ist grundsätzlich nicht erlaubt, diese Datenspeicherung anzulegen, aber die passiert ja.
Vielleicht verstehst du auch dieses Wort grundsätzlich anders.
Hast, damit meinen die Juristen, es ist nicht okay und dann kommt so ein Aber
und sie haben im konkreten Fall dann diese oder jene Regelung, die eben doch erlauben.
Das ist nicht grundsätzlich im Sinne von nein, nein, nein, das darfst du nicht,
sondern das ist erstmal nicht okay, aber für diese oder jene spezielle Regelung
kann man das absolut notwendige Bestrengung tun.
Also vielleicht hängst du da zu sehr an der Alltagssprache und bist nicht sozusagen
diese juristische Das ist korrekt, dafür bin ich ja hier.
Ich bin auch kein Jurist. Wir haben ja schon so oft diese Urteile gelesen.
So, okay, wir müssen jetzt noch zwei Dinge klären. Das eine ist ...
Das klang ja schon an, aber ich hätte gerne, dass es nochmal expliziert.
Was wird das für politische Folgen in Deutschland haben?
Also wird jetzt jemand ankommen und sagen, auch wenn es vielleicht juristisch
keinen Sinn macht, hey, lass mal fort zur Ansprechung machen und danach sprechen
wir über die Alternativen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir heute noch zu den Alternativen kommen.
Ich glaube nur, dass alle Daniels Linie fahren werden.
Es hat sich auch sehr festgesetzt, das Urteil ist so kommentiert worden,
alle werden sagen, hier geht doch jetzt irgendwie.
Man könnte es so formulieren, selbst als es klare Absagen gab von den Gerichten,
das geht nicht und sozusagen die Kommentierung war, ist ausgeschlossen,
gab es trotzdem eine Fraktion, die gesagt hat, brauchen wir aber trotzdem.
Und diese Fraktion wird ja jetzt nicht sagen, wo die Tür ein bisschen aufgeht,
ah jetzt wollen wir nicht mehr, sondern das wird natürlich eher benutzt, um zu sagen,
naja, im Prinzip das, was wir jetzt schon haben, die Gerichte erlauben es,
liebe Bundesregierung,
warum macht ihr es nicht, ihr, jeden Tag passieren Straftaten und ihr könntet
es eigentlich abstellen.
Das ist sozusagen der politische Druck, der gerade aus der Opposition aufgebaut wird.
Darf ich nochmal quick freeze sagen? Ja, da kommen wir ja gleich zu.
Nein, vielleicht passt es jetzt aber gerade. Sonst kann man ja nicht über die
Einigung reden, die gerade besteht.
Ich wollte noch kurz gefragt haben von den großen Parteien, die im Bundestag
sitzen, von den größeren demokratischen Parteien, die im Bundesrat sitzen.
Kann man das klar verorten für Gegenvorratsdatenspeicherung?
Das Bundeskastenweißbrot möchte Quick Freeze.
Bundeskasten, weil ich wohne. Nein, ich glaube, man kann nicht...
Leute, jetzt mach ich's halt. Was sagt die CDU dazu? Die Union?
Ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht immer bei jeder Partei für vielleicht gibt
es immer mal eine Person, die da irgendwie sagt, ich würde es anders sehen,
aber im Wesentlichen kann man sagen, die Linke, die Grünen und die FDP sind
eher bis klar gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Bei der Union kann man sagen, die sind eher bis klar dafür.
Und bei der SPD kommt es schon relativ stark an zu welchem politikfeld arbeiten
die leute also die innenpolitiker der spd sind eher dafür dann gibt es aber
auch wirklich viele bei der spd die sagen das geht mit uns so nicht,
genau und deswegen ist gerade einfach weil
wir im moment eben grünen und fdp in der bundesregierung haben war da relativ
klar steht ja auch im koalitionsvertrag so eine vorratsansprechung wird es nicht
geben sondern eben quick freeze aber meine persönliche meinung ist schon das
dass sollte die Union in die Bundesregierung kommen mit einer SPD,
also wenn es wieder eine GroKo gäbe.
Dann kann ich mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung
wieder eingeführt würde.
Also Menschen mit Vorbehalten gegenüber Grundrechtseinschränkungen in der SPD,
die haben die grundsätzlich schon immer mit argem Bauchweh, aber dann doch mit
Entschärfung. Genau, also ich meine Heiko Maas hat sie damals eingeführt,
der SPD-Justizminister.
Naja, aber sie haben es schon unterschrieben, Daniel hat erwähnt,
sie haben es unterschrieben im Koalitionsvertrag.
Keine anlasslosen Massenspeicherung. Naja, aber der kommt ja auch wieder zu
Wahlen. Also von daher, mal sehen.
Spannend wird es sein, wenn wir sowas wie Schwarz-Grün oder so bekämen,
wie, weiß man ja nicht, aber falls, dann wäre es schon interessant,
schaffen es die Grünen, sich dann da zu widersetzen, weil für die Union ist
das schon ein richtig wichtiges Thema.
So, aber es gibt Alternativen. Quick Freeze. Verbrecherfangen im Internet mit Quick Freeze.
Das klingt wie so ein geiles Produkt. Was ist das?
Naja, Ja, da wollen wir jetzt natürlich auch nicht... Nibbler hat so viel Quick-Freeze,
den muss er erst noch jetzt erklären, oder?
Der Punkt, den ich aufmachen wollte, ist, dass es bei der Speicherfrist halt
ein Kontinuum gibt und dass auf der einen Seite des Kontinuums eben dieser Quick-Freeze,
dass es die kürzest mögliche oder kürzest vorstellbare Speicherdauer ist.
Nämlich so lange, wie das eh beim Provider anfällt. Und das finde ich halt eine
spannende Diskussion, weil eigentlich fallen diese Daten zwar an,
aber es gibt immer weniger Gründe diese Daten aufzuheben. Deswegen,
Bin ich mir nicht sicher, inwieweit der diskutierte Quick-Freeze,
also von wie vielen Tagen reden wir da?
Du kannst jetzt nicht sozusagen, wenn ich frage, was ist Quick-Freeze,
mit der Kritik an Quick-Freeze anfangen, sondern was ist denn Quick-Freeze?
Das war nicht die Kritik an Quick-Freeze, die kommt noch. Quick-Freeze ist das
Einfrieren der vorhandenen Daten.
Also das, was sie sozusagen technisch wegspeichern, vorhin hat der Nibbler ein paar Details gesagt,
dass die eingefroren werden ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo ein Strafverfolger sagt,
na, die hätten wir gerne und dann muss nochmal ein Richter drüber gucken und
wenn der sagt, das ist hier wirklich ein ernsthafter Verdacht,
dann werden die übergeben.
Und ab dem Zeitpunkt in die Zukunft kann man dann auch sagen,
man möchte jetzt Daten speichern aus dem und dem konkreten Grund,
das ist ja heute schon möglich.
Stopp, Moment. Wenn ich das jetzt als Alternative zur Vorratsansprechung höre,
hört es jetzt für mich an, es gibt in Deutschland einen Schalter und wenn also
jemand dann sagt, Quick Freeze, dann wird der Schalter umgelegt und dann wird
überall Daten gespeichert.
Ich hätte jetzt für sinnvoller gehalten, maybe that's just me,
wenn man sagt Quick Freeze, dass es dann, man hat schon den Verdacht,
also es betrifft dann einen Anschluss oder einen Anbieter oder ein Aha.
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht für die gesamte Bevölkerung, sondern das ist wirklich
so, Stell dir vor, es gibt eine Beleidigung oder so im Netz,
die vielleicht eine schwere Straftat erfüllen würde, warum auch immer.
Und dann weißt du aber nicht, wer steckt eigentlich in diesem Facebook-Account.
Dann kann es sein, dass du als Strafverfolgungsbehörde im Moment das Problem hast,
weil dir einfach manche Abläufe noch relativ lang sind, dass du in diesen zwei,
drei Tagen, was wenig klingt, aber das genau die Zeit ist, wo vielleicht Daten
aus technischen Gründen beim Netzbetreiber gelöscht würden.
Dann kannst du eben diesen Button drücken, verbildlich gesagt,
und sagen, wir haben da vielleicht was, wir möchten uns das im Zweifel angucken
und sozusagen die Formale erreichen.
Aber das heißt, ich müsste schon sozusagen eine IP-Adresse wissen.
Genau, ja, also zumindest brauchst du, du musst irgendwas haben,
wo du auf jemanden zugehst und sagst, wir müssen zu diesem,
wir wissen nicht genau, wer dahinter steckt, das ist ja immer bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
das wollte ich eben schon einmal gesagt haben, es geht nicht so sehr darum,
wir sehen da die Konstanz und wir wollen wissen, was die so alles tut,
sondern der Standardfall bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist eher,
wir wissen nicht, wer dahinter steckt und sag du uns bitte, wer steckt hinter
diesen technischen Daten, das ist eigentlich der Anwendungsfall.
Genau, aber das heißt sozusagen, für Quick-Freeze brauche ich ein Telekommunikationsdatum.
Also weil du gerade gesagt hast, Facebook-Account.
Du brauchst grundsätzlich, um mit der VDS irgendwas anzufangen,
ein Kommunikationsdatum. Das ist die Übersetzung von einem Kommunikationsdatum in eine Person.
Ja, der Klassiker wäre dann, du fragst bei Facebook, mit welcher IP-Adresse
wurde sich der eingeloggt, dann kriegst du die IP-Adresse und dann musst du
ja wiederum zum Netzbetreiber rennen und sagen, wer nutzt die denn gerade.
Genau, das war mir wichtig, sozusagen gerade noch klarzustellen,
weil du musst. Ja, aber ein bisschen genauer müssen wir schon sein.
Also, weil alle Beispiele sind jetzt, also es liegt ein Gesetzentwurf dafür vor.
Der ist zwar schon ein bisschen älter, der ist von 2022, also,
ne, und da soll es jetzt auch einen neuen geben und da werden sie vielleicht
ein paar andere Sachen machen, aber es bezieht sich jetzt nicht unbedingt nur
auf so ein einspezifisches Ding.
Es kann schon auch einen größeren Rahmen Einfrierung geben. Was heißt größerer Rahmen?
Naja, man könnte ja auch sagen, ich brauche zum Beispiel mal die Daten von bestimmten Funkzellen oder so.
Also das muss jetzt nicht so klein sein. Es gibt auch Kritik an dem Quick-Freeze-Verfahren
aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht. Nee, aber stopp, stopp, stopp. Den Scope erstmal
erklären, also die Ausweitung.
Also entweder hast du ein konkretes Telekommunikationsdatum oder du kannst es
weiterfassen. Das Weiterfassen ist zum Beispiel eine Funkzelle.
Ist das auch ein kompletter Telekommunikationsanbieter oder ein Stadtteil oder
wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Ne, je nachdem, was du für eine Straftat verfolgen
wirst und wo sozusagen dein Ansatz ist, du kannst erst mal sagen,
es wird auch mehr Daten einfrieren.
Und daran macht sich jetzt die Kritik fest. Aber es ist sozusagen beschränkt
auf Telekommunikationsanbieter.
Also sie sagen nicht, also man könnte ja auch sowas machen, wie das mal bei
sozialen Netzwerken sagt, du musst eine gewisse Weile vorhalten,
welche IP-Adressen sich auf den Account connected haben oder so.
Aber es geht nur um die, die wirklich die technische Infrastruktur, Telekommunikation.
Okay, gut, danke.
Kritik. In Basel im Wesentlichen schon. Also es gibt Verbände von Berufsgeheimnisträgern,
die natürlich da sagen, also im Detail müsste man da schon nochmal drauf schauen,
weil wir bestimmte Berufsgruppen haben, die klassische Berufsgeheimnisträger
sind und da müsste man vielleicht ein paar Ausnahmen machen bei der Einfrägerei,
weil dann meine Mandanten zum Beispiel,
wenn ich ein Anwalt bin oder meine Quellen als Journalist in einer besonderen
Gefährdung ausgesetzt sind.
Also ein zweistufiges Verfahren zum Beispiel, also wer prüft,
ob dieses Einfrägen auch okay war, sowas.
Aber das heißt ja eigentlich sozusagen, dass man, also wenn diese Kritik stattgegeben
werden würde, würde das ja wiederum bedeuten, du kannst dann das nicht mehr
machen, dass du eine Funkzelle einfrierst, weil dann hast du ja im Zweifel diese Leute dabei.
Wie gesagt, das ist eher so ein rechtliches Ding. Wer guckt da drauf und prüft,
ob es okay ist? Also es geht erst mal um die Schnelligkeit.
Wir haben das noch nicht erwähnt. Also die ganze Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatte
geht auch immer darum, dass diese Daten flüchtig sind in diesem Sinne von Strafverfolgern.
Leute müssen schnell handeln, um Daten, die irgendwo beim Telekommunikationsanbieter
vorliegen, einfrieren, festhalten haben zu können.
Und QuickFreeze soll genau das leisten. Erstmal schnell einfrieren,
aber wichtig ist natürlich für das Gesetz, wie ist es ausgestaltet danach?
Wer entscheidet, ob die wirklich in großen Mengen dann auch weitergegeben werden? Frage.
Diese Kritik, bestimmte Berufsgruppen sollen da ausgeschlossen werden.
Bezieht sich das darauf, dass deren Daten gar nicht erst gespeichert werden dürfen?
Oder bezieht sich das darauf, dass wenn die, keine Ahnung, aus Versehen oder
im Treibnetz irgendwie mit, also Mobilfunkzelle irgendwie wurde komplett,
quick freest und sagt die Kritik dann, ihr müsst erst mal gucken und wenn dann
Geheimnis regelt, dann müssen die rausgenommen werden und dann dürfen die Daten erst benutzen?
Das ist die ganz große Kritik, das wo ich sage, wenn wir anlasslose.
Massenüberwachung wollen, dann müssen wir uns eingestehen, dass es niemals ein
perfektes Verfahren gibt, um bestimmte Individuen, die wir eigentlich schützen
und rausnehmen wollen, da rechtssicher rausfiltern können.
Denn entweder wir haben diesen Ansatz erstmal alles und dann ist es ja nur möglich,
wirklich bestimmte Leute rauszufiltern, wenn ich die irgendwie entweder kennzeichne
bei der Erfassung, das ist dein Punkt so, ja, ganz ehrlich, das will ich nicht.
Also ich will jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie an meiner Handynummer ein digitales
Wimpel hängt, der ist übrigens Journalist und redet mit interessanten Leuten, auf gar keinen Fall.
Das heißt, es wird dann eher klassischerweise darauf kommen,
naja, wenn man die Daten abfragt und man erkennt dann, oh, das sind hier irgendwie
schützenswerte Personen, dann dürfen wir die vielleicht doch nicht herausgreifen.
Das klingt juristisch immer ganz toll, in der Praxis ist das,
sorry, totaler Bullshit. Also
da guckt jemand drauf und die haben doch mit der Materie nichts zu tun.
Du kannst doch jetzt nicht von Leuten bei einem Netzbetreiber verlangen,
dass die noch eine juristische Prüfung machen.
Ist der Journalist, ist der irgendwas und das rechtssicher und so weiter,
das glaube ich einfach nicht.
Also dem will ich einfach nicht vertrauen. Also natürlich könnten wir das aufheizen,
aber das ist einfach etwas, wo ich sage, das ist nichts, wo ich als Journalist
dann sage, ach so, wenn es so ist, dann ist es doch nicht so schlimm.
Dann vertraue ich doch wieder auf den Quellenschutz. Das mag man dann alles so tun.
Aber das ist nichts, wo ich von meiner grundsätzlichen Kritik dann für meine
Berufsgruppe abweiche.
Das mag dann vielleicht den Schaden etwas begrenzen in dem, was man geht.
Aber indem man sich entschieden hat, wir machen diese anlasslose Massenüberwachung,
müssen wir uns klar sein, dass dort immer Kollateralschäden rausputzeln werden,
die wir nicht komplett wegfiltern können.
Naja, man muss eins hinzufügen. Selbstverständlich und das müssen auch,
das ist geltendes Recht, Provider, die Anforderungen kriegen,
zum Beispiel zum Abhören, müssen prüfen.
Sie tun das nicht immer so, aber es gibt auch eine rechtliche Prüfung bei allen
großen Providern, ob diese Anforderungen, die die kriegen, rechtmäßig sind.
Aber was im Gesetz so stehen soll, ist ja nicht, zumindest nach dem Entwurf,
der diskutiert wurde, der ja auch nochmal anders wird, aber es ist ja nicht,
dass die Provider das tun sollen, sondern es soll ja ein Richtervorbehalt sein.
Und dem Richter würde ich schon zumindest
erst mal anders vertrauen als irgendeinem Justiziar in der Telco.
Der Richter sagt Quick Freeze ja oder nein oder der guckt sich die Daten an
und sagt, welche davon verwendet werden?
Nein, also der sagt, ob die eingefrorenen Daten, ob sozusagen, ja, rechtmäßig ist.
Da bin ich das glaube ich nicht, Konstanze.
Klassischerweise ist es so, dass eine Ermittlungsbehörde sagt,
Hier ist ein Vorfall, hier geht es um das Delikt, wir wissen nicht genau,
wer dahinter steckt, glauben aber, das ist hier schwere Kriminalität oder was
auch immer und die Rahmenbedingungen passen, dass wir die Daten sehen.
Dann sagt der Richter, stimmt, sehe
ich auch so und dann kriegt aber die Strafverfolgungsbehörde die Daten.
Da sagt jetzt nicht nochmal ein Richter und geht durch und guckt und dann sagt,
dann googelt er die Personen, die da irgendwie rauskommen und sagt,
oh Moment mal, sind ja Leute, die investigativ arbeiten oder die irgendwie Therapeuten sind und so.
Und das ist der Punkt, glaube ich. Und zweifelt gar nicht die Zeit dafür,
gerade wenn ich mir anschaue, wie das mit dem Richtervorbehalt funktioniert.
Das sind Sekunden im Zweifel, die da auf den Vorfall gehen. Und da sind wir
dann auch wieder bei der Kehrtwende von eben der Frage, worauf ich mit dem Quick-Face
hinaus wollte, mit der Zeit.
In dem Moment, wo wir überlastete Behörden haben,
die im Zweifel Wochen später auf Daten zugreifen wollen, alleine dadurch entsteht
ja schon der scheinbare Bedarf für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
wären die nicht dermaßen überlastet.
Wäre eine Quick-Freeze-Lösung für die problemlos ein tägliches Werkzeug,
mit dem sie arbeiten können, mit dem sie sagen können, diese Daten hätten wir
jetzt gerne, bitte mal kurz festhalten, Dankeschön.
Und da bräuchte man dann gar keine... Und alle Alternativen haben genau diese
Schnelligkeit im Fokus.
Gibt es noch andere? Ja, wir haben also gestern, es gab in Berlin eine große
Konferenz, wo über diese unter
anderem anslose Massenspeicherung und die Attentiven gesprochen wurde.
Und da geht es vor allen Dingen, also für mich jetzt etwa noch um die Lock-In-Falle.
Das ist auch so ein Mittel, können wir jetzt sicherlich nicht im Detail erklären,
aber wo man schnell möglichst jemand handeln will, um ihn in eine Falle zu locken.
Also etwa wenn es um Beleidigung geht oder um Rechtsverletzung und so.
Also es gibt schon Attentiven. Du musst trotzdem sagen, was ist eine Lock-In-Falle?
Das hört sich an wie so ein Scam. Ich setze eine Webseite auf und versuche,
dass sie sich da einloggt?
Ja, nein, du versuchst keinen Scam aufzusetzen, sondern du versuchst jemanden
festzunageln und zu warten, bis er sich das nächste Mal einloggt.
Also ihm eine Falle zu stellen. Das ist ein bisschen komplexeres Konzept.
Das gilt dann auch sozusagen für Plattformen und nicht nur für Telekommunikationsanbieter.
Ja und vor allen Dingen ist es aber wiederum die Schnelligkeit.
Und da müssen wir in der Diskussion glaube ich hin, zu sagen,
wir sind irgendwie in der Neuzeit, die müssen schnell reagieren,
ansonsten droht uns diese anlasslose Massenspeicherung.
Denn nur wenn die schnell agieren können, können die mit anderen Maßnahmen eine
ordentliche Strafverfolgung machen. Aber das ist schon ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied zu früher.
Wir reden nicht mehr darüber, dass wir keine Überwachungsschnittstellen im Netz
haben wollen. Also ich war noch nie ein Streitverfolger, falls du das sagen wolltest.
Es gab früher durchaus die Argumentation und die Position, dass man sagt,
wir wollen keinerlei Vorratssatzspeicherungsähnliche Konzepte haben,
weil das immer ein Einfallstor ist für anlasslose Massenüberwachung.
Man kann auch die grundsätzliche Frage aufmachen, wollen wir Geheimdienste in
unserem Staat tragen, die was Positives zu bei oder nicht beitragen.
Also da kann man alles grundsätzlich diskutieren. Ich glaube,
was sich ja schon geändert hat, ist einfach diese Schnelligkeit,
die jetzt auch einfach technisch viel mehr möglich geworden ist.
Und was mir in den Recherchen zur Pedikriminalität nicht einleuchtet,
ist, es gibt das sogenannte NECMEC-Verfahren.
Das klingt kompliziert, ist aber eigentlich ganz einfach. Wenn du ein großes
Social Network zum Beispiel in den USA bist, dann hast du die Pflicht,
wenn du automatisiert siehst, da werden irgendwie Missbrauchsdarstellungen geteilt,
das wird automatisiert mit Hashen geprüft und dann wird das auch sozusagen die
IP-Adresse gesammelt von den Leuten, dann wird das so in die Welt verteilt sozusagen.
Zu sagen, wenn klar ist, es ist eine IP-Adresse wahrscheinlich aus Deutschland
und wird es in Deutschland geschickt.
Das dauert mindestens mehrere Tage, bis das in Deutschland angekommen ist.
Das verstehe ich schlichtweg nicht.
Also das sind große Social Network, das ist eine große Kinderschutzorganisation
und das ist so ein wichtiges Verfahren und es vergehen immer viele,
viele Tage, bis eine IP-Adresse vom Teilen selber da ist, dass das jetzt nicht
vielleicht instantly da ist.
Okay, aber dass das so nach 10, 20 Minuten oder so, in einem automatisierten Verfahren hier ist.
Weißt du, wann an welcher Stelle in diesem Prozess der Verzug entsteht?
Ja, also meiner Kenntnis nach ist es vor allen Dingen NECMEC,
also diese Stelle, die das eben dann weiterverteilen muss, aber da bin ich jetzt
nicht komplett sattelfest, aber.
Genau und auch, was man so hört, ist es jetzt auch nicht so,
dass auf Seiten der deutschen Strafverfolgungsbehörden das dann alles automatisiert
immer durchweg weiter verteilt wird.
Also das heißt, da gibt es schon, da bin ich voll bei Konstanze,
es gibt schon einige prozessuale Schritte, sage ich mal, die einfach deutlich
optimiert werden könnten, um einfach massiv Zeit zu gewinnen.
Also ich meine, seit dem Jahrzehnt. Wir reden ja auch nicht über jetzt.
Das war die ganze Zeit am Anfang, meinte er. Diese ganzen Versteifer auf die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben die Alternativen einfach mal ignoriert, ein ganzes Jahrzehnt.
Und dann kommen sie mit den schlimmen Zahlen, wo ich so sage,
naja, hättet ihr aber auch schon vor zehn Jahren, denn die Vorschläge sind teilweise
schon so alt. Quick Freeze ist von, haltet euch fest, 2011, Sabine Leutheuser-Schnarrenberger.
Ey, weißt du, wie viel Zeit das ist? Die Login-Falle ist jünger.
Also die ist jetzt so, weiß ich nicht, drei Jahre alt oder so.
Aber durch diese, oh Gott, wir wollen alles immer speichern,
ist natürlich auch viel verloren gegangen, was man ausprobieren hätte können,
weißt du, und schneller machen können.
Und ich finde es infam, den Leuten zu unterstellen, die gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
sind. Sie hätten was prinzipiell gegen Überwachung.
Ich finde es korrekt, dass man Leute, gegen die ein begründeter Verdacht besteht, überwacht.
Da geht es nie darum, komplett Überwachung zu verhindern, sondern es geht darum,
dass wir die Bevölkerung nicht anlasslos speichern wollen. Ich finde,
das ist ein politisches Argument, ich weiß und so, aber ich ziehe den Schuh mir überhaupt nicht an.
Und ich wüsste auch nicht, dass in der ganzen Freiheit statt Angstdemo es jemals
darum ging, sich für irgendwelche Straftäter zu stellen, sondern es ging immer
darum, sich für die Bevölkerung einzusetzen, die einfach mal ein Recht hat,
dass ihre Daten nicht festgehalten werden. Das ist vor allem ein Asymmetrie-Ding.
Wir haben eine Handvoll Straftäter, wir haben eine Handvoll Strafverfolger.
Das ist auf Augenhöhe. Wenn man von allen Bürgern alle Daten speichert und die
einem kleinen Teil der Bevölkerung zugänglich macht, dann schafft man da eine Machtasymmetrie.
Na gut. Das ist was ganz anderes als eine Schauverfolgung. Jetzt ist ja die
Frage, ich habe gerade in meinem Kopf so ein bisschen eine Abschlussfrage gefeilt und war so,
es ist, ja, nee, nee, ich glaube nicht, sondern ich glaube, im Sinne der Telefunden,
Telenovela ist eigentlich die Frage, wann treffen wir uns das nächste Mal wieder,
um über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu sprechen? Eine Weile nicht.
Denn diese Pläneumscheidung, die ja heute der Anlass war, also die vom 30.
April, wird erstmal für eine ziemlich lange Zeit die letzte sein.
Dann steht nichts mehr an.
Also du weißt ja immer schon, das dauert immer sehr lange.
Du konntest ja immer schon absehen, wann ungefähr die Urteile kommen.
Und erstmal wird aus zumindest vom EuGH nichts mehr kommen.
Na, aber wir treffen uns ja möglicherweise nicht nur, wenn das EuGH was entscheidet.
Wir treffen uns ja vielleicht auch, wenn also...
Dann würde ich sagen, nächstes Jahr im Herbst oder Winter. Wenn die AfD mit der CDU regiert?
Ich glaube, dann müssten wir uns nicht treffen, weil dann wäre die Sache wahrscheinlich
durch. Wobei ich muss fairerweise sagen, ich weiß gar nicht,
was die AfD zu dem Thema sagt.
Ich vermute es mal, aber ich gucke mir jetzt deren Wahlprogramm nicht an.
Ich finde auch nicht gut, wenn wir solche Schreckensszenarien annehmen.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass in dieses Thema, ob wir wollen oder nicht,
wird politisch Bewegung kommen nach der Bundestagswahl.
Es sei denn, wir haben Die müssen sich ja erst mal konstituieren.
Glaubt ihr alle nicht mehr, dass Quick Freeze in dieser Legislatur kommt?
Doch, das kann sein, aber ich glaube nicht, dass... Aber würden wir deswegen
ein Chaosradio machen, ist die Frage.
Nein, ich glaube vor allen Dingen, dass Quick Freeze die Debatte nicht beenden
wird, weil ja jetzt schon Strafverfolgungsbehörden sagen, das ist nett,
aber es reicht uns nicht.
Und das sagen die sehr klar auch in Pressestatements und deswegen,
und die Union wird das auch weiterhin pushen, also das Thema wird bleiben.
Naja, zumindest wäre ja auch die Zeit relativ knapp. Man muss ja auch mal über
eine ernstzunehmende Evaluierung reden.
Da müsste mal jemand draufgucken und sagen, wie gut funktioniert das,
wie effizient ist das, wo muss man dann noch an Schrauben drehen.
Und dafür wird die Zeit auch zu knapp sein bis zur nächsten Regierung.
Das ist natürlich auch auf jeden Fall so. Insofern, da würde ich mich da an den anschließen.
Was denkst du, Nibbler, wann werden wir uns das nächste Mal treffen? Puh.
Wenn man dich fragt. Grobe Verabredung in so ungefähr zwei Jahren, sag ich mal.
Nächste Bundestagswahl plus Warmlaufen, Gesetzesvorschläge machen.
Naja, es könnte ja irgendwann noch was anderes passieren.
Es könnte ja immer noch passieren, dass mal ein kompletter Vorratsdatenspeicherungssatz
eines Landes abhanden kommt.
Könnte ja noch passieren. Dann würde sich die Debatte, ich bin ja auch sehr
gerne am Thema IT-Sicherheit, vielleicht auch nochmal wandeln.
Ja, okay. Also falls ihr da Zugänge habt, der CCC ist da, glaube ich,
dankbarer Abnehmer im Zweifelsfall.
Ja und ich glaube, was schon auch, glaube ich, wichtig wird,
ist, dass wir auch noch stärker konstanter, das hat es ja gesagt,
dass auch in Europa viele andere Länder das haben.
Wir hantieren hier teilweise noch mit empirischen Daten, sozusagen,
was hat die Vorratsdatenspeicherung damals gebracht.
Die sind schon sehr, sehr alt, mittlerweile 15 Jahre oder mehr, diese Erhebung.
Ich glaube persönlich, dass das noch sehr, sehr wertvoll wäre,
eigentlich mal zu gucken in einem Land wie Italien, die haben glaube ich auch
eine relativ umfangreiche Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Wie sieht es da eigentlich aus, seitdem die das haben mit der Kriminalitätsentwicklung
in bestimmten Deliktsbereichen, wo man immer sagt, genau da würde es was bringen.
Ich glaube, das wäre schon hilfreich, da noch Zeit rein zu investieren, dort mehr zu wissen.
Das wird auch gemacht. Zumindest ist es in Europa auch ein Thema,
die Evaluierung einzuholen.
Mein Fazit, um den Bogen nochmal zu schließen, ich hatte ja am Anfang gesagt,
dass das, an das ich mich erinnere damals, ist, dass es sehr lange der Fall
war, dass Vorratsdaten gespeichert wurden, bis das ein Gericht einkassiert hat.
Und mein Fazit ist, das, was ich damals mir als Handlungsanweisung daraus abgeleitet
habe, kommuniziere so, dass keine Vorratsdaten anfallen.
Zumindest keine, die dich verraten. Zumindest keine, die mich verraten.
Und Jetzt muss ich noch kurz die technische Anleitung, wie das geht.
Es gibt bestimmt mehrere Chaos-Radio-Folgen, die wir verlinken können.
Man kann sich natürlich auch Dienstleister suchen, wo keine Metadaten anfallen, also man kann schon.
Aber das ist oft mit einer technischen Expertise verbunden. Und das muss man
ja auch. Ich dachte, Telekom reicht.
Habt ihr gerade einen Telekom-Werbeblock gemacht? Kannst du aufs SpaceNet gehen?
SpaceNet und Telekom müssen nicht Vorratszeiten speichern.
Na gut, das wäre dann wahrscheinlich tatsächlich aber nochmal eine eigene Sendung,
um das nochmal ausführlich aufzudröseln. Wir würden an dieser Stelle uns,
glaube ich, eher verabschieden.
Vielen Dank Daniel, Nibbler und Konz.
Und Markus. Das war mal wieder, danke schön, danke schön, das war mal wieder
ein längeres Chaos-Radio. Mal gucken.
Genau, bis zum, wisst ihr schon, was er in der nächsten Folge dicke Bretter macht?
Ja, kann ich aber nicht verraten, tut mir leid. Also wir haben da so ein NDA
unterzeichnet. Aber es wird mega geil. Schaltet wieder ein.
So soll es sein. Bis dahin dürft ihr natürlich eine Sache Sachen nicht vergessen.
Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Und wählen gehen. Tschüss.
Music.